Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Exquisite Leute, da sind wir.
Weeps in oder out ist die Frage. Heute machen wir mal wieder was zur Abwechslung.
NickQ29 angeschrieben im Prime-Sub. Das ist ja massive.
Eindeutig Moin. Auch wenn Gude eher hessisch ist, nee, nee. Ich bin für Moin. Gude ist zwar eher hessisch, aber ich bin tatsächlich eher so dem Nordischen da verbunden, was das angeht. Ich bin eher für Moin.
Was ist denn heute die Begrüßung unter coolen Leuten? Was sagt man da so? Digga. Was geht Digga? Digga. Digga. Digga muss man ja sagen.
Yo, yo, Digga, fühl ich. Ja, das ist glaube ich richtig. 08max07, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. 7 Monate. Massive Subscriptions hier wieder. Kann man ein bisschen kleiner machen, den Kram.
Minify fährt. Guck mal, der Felix ist am Start. Moin, ne?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ob man das... Nee, nee, nee. Digga. Digga innen, wenn schon. Also, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes. Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich muss mal kurz die VMs starten, dass das... Dass ich euch das demonstriere. Ach du Scheiße, wie viele VMs haben wir jetzt hier eigentlich mittlerweile.
Ich blick dann einmal durch. Hab ich überhaupt noch Plattenplatz? Lass mal kurz kontrollieren. Oh.
Okay, vielleicht soll ich mal wieder ein paar VMs löschen, ne?
Der Desktop. Ich weiß gar nicht, was der Chat immer mit dem Desktop hat. Ich mein, erstens ist der Desktop wegen euch so voll.
Was meint ihr denn? Hab ich aus Spaß und Freude irgendwie 30 Milliarden Emails drauf?
Und zweitens blick ich da durch. Ihr könnt mich alles fragen, was auf dem Desktop steht. Innerhalb von 10 Sekunden habe ich es gefunden. 5 Sekunden. 5 Sekunden. Easy.
Also, wer da nicht durchblickt, weiß ich auch nicht. So, also. Welche VM war denn jetzt auch mal die richtige? Das hier ist die Stream-VM, ne? Genau.
Twitch, wo ist die Benachrichtigung? Ja, was soll das?
Demnächst braucht man auch noch, wie bei YouTube, dass es nicht mehr reicht, dass man followt und subscribt, dann muss man demnächst auch noch die Glocke machen, wie auf YouTube, dass das so funktioniert.
Was haben wir denn hier noch auf? Ah, guck mal, war das der Raspberry Pi?
Wir könnten auch den Raspberry Pi nehmen, um das zu machen, was ich heute machen will. Schauen wir mal. Bin ich mir bloß nicht ganz sicher, ob es die ganzen Images dafür gibt.
Also, was wir heute machen, was wir machen, ich zeige es euch mal. Massive Big Brain Idee.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz updaten, wer weiß, was da... Ach du Scheiße, ich habe schon ewig nicht mehr geupdatet. Twitch hat schon eine Glocke gestimmt, hast recht.
Ich lasse mal kurz updaten. Also, ich zeige euch mal nebenbei, was wir heute machen. Also, wir machen heute zwei Sachen. Einmal, das kennt vielleicht der eine oder andere, das ist ein Passport-Save.
Der wurde jetzt umbenannt, weil wahrscheinlich die originalen Bitwarden-Projekt-Typen ein bisschen Stress gemacht haben. Das ist ein Passport-Save.
Und ihr wisst, ich verwende Key Pass, aber ein paar Leute haben schon immer gesagt, hier probier das mal aus. Ich habe das vor zwei Jahren oder so ausprobiert und da habe ich mir so gedacht, ja, also großartig umziehen will ich nicht.
Aber, aber, es ist ja gar nicht der Punkt, ob ich das jetzt verwenden will oder nicht. Was wir heute machen, ist nämlich noch was anderes. Das lässt sich damit nämlich gut demonstrieren.
Was auch quasi jedes Mal, wenn ich hier irgendwie was aufmache, sei es von meinem Staubsauger, wobei der Staubsauger hat kein gültiges Zertifikat, oder? Hab ich den Zertifikat verpasst mittlerweile im Staubsauger?
Nee. Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendeinen lokalen Service aufmache und ihr seht, dass das ein gültiges Zertifikat hat, dann fragen die Leute im Chat immer, wie gehen das?
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen heute den Massive Brain, also Huge IQ DevOps Experten Ansatz und wir installieren uns lokal einen Passwort Manager.
Checken das natürlich auch alles schön ins Shit ein, machen dann Reverse Proxy davor, der über Cloudflare DNS Challenge Zertifikate holt.
Und alles so, dass man es irgendwie versteht, hoffe ich mal.
Ja und natürlich wird es in Shitrepo eingecheckt, das muss sein. Das muss sein. Und danach kommt der Test, ob ihr weiter gucken dürft. Danach wird abgefragt.
Ich glaube es sind keine, sag mal sind keine Monster? Ich glaube es sind tatsächlich keine Monster.
Übrigens ich mache heute mal den Test. Ich habe heute mal wieder gestellt auf, wartet mal. Klar ist das Prüfungsrelevant. Meint ihr ich mache das zum Spaß?
Also ich mache heute mal den Test. Ich stream heute mal wieder in Science and Technology. Man sollte ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass Science and Technology so die Kategorie ist, wo man mit so einem Content mehr Viewer kriegt.
Aber in der Regel habe ich immer in Just Chatting mehr Viewer einfach, weil mehr Viewer vorbeikommen und hängen bleiben.
Also eigentlich ist das die bessere Kategorie, aber die Kategorie guckt keiner auf Twitch. Deswegen ist die andere Kategorie, die eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht ist, besser.
Das muss man nicht verstehen, aber es scheint so zu sein. Aber gucken wir mal, ob das heute auch so ist.
Ach ja Felix, danke für den Sub. Das glaube ich schon gesagt, aber schön, dass du da bist.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob ich einen Titel so lassen soll. Das versteht ja kein Mensch. Das versteht der Chat.
Guck mal, wenn jemand keine Ahnung hat, was Sache ist und er liest CloudNative5 hat DevOps Experte macht Hacker man.
Der macht den Stream noch nicht auf. Der denkt sich einfach nur CacWade und geht weiter, weil wer will schon einen Stream mit so einem Kacktitel joinen?
Wir machen den Titel mal andersrum. Wir machen Passwort Save, Lokale, Let's Encrypt, Site Defeat Karte, Docker Git.
Das machen wir als erstes hin. Das machen wir als erstes hin. Und danach machen wir CloudNative5 hat DevOps Experte macht Hacker man.
Huge. So rum ist es besser. Da sehen die Leute nämlich gleich schon, was passiert. Guck mal, habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell Twitch das mittlerweile anpasst?
Gesaved und easy. Wir haben schon viele Firefights. Ich meine, ihr wisst ja, jeder Sub ein IQ mehr für den Chat.
Das heißt, mittlerweile ist der Cop eigentlich schon fast am explodieren. Guckt euch das mal an. Guckt euch das mal an.
Wir haben noch 2 Minuten 55 Zeit für den Hype Train. Ihr müsst euch mal ein bisschen mehr scammen lassen von Twitch.
Siehste? Geht doch. Funktioniert doch. Wunderbar. 12 Monate Mark LDMM. Danke schön für den Sub. 12 Monate ist ja schon Hypersubscription.
Also die Hälfte haben wir geschafft. Wir haben noch 2 Minuten 30 Zeit, dass ihr Jeff noch ein bisschen Geld überweisen könnt.
Der hat es nötig. Vielleicht gibt er ja Bill Gates was ab. Bill Gates lässt sich jetzt ja scheiden, habe ich gehört.
Das kostet sicherlich viel Geld. Danach ist er nicht mehr der reichste. Nein, danach gehört er nicht mehr zu den reichsten Männern der Welt.
Das ist jetzt vorbei. Die Zeiten, die Zeiten sind abgehakt.
Angeblich kann man einstellen, wann der Hype Train auslöst. Du weißt, ich bin zwar auf Twitch und ich benutze Twitch, aber ich kenne mich mit Twitch eigentlich gar nicht aus.
Da müsste ich mal nachgucken. Kann schon sein, dass das geht.
Aber sie ist dann die reichste Frau. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer ist denn gerade die reichste Frau. Reichste Frau der Welt.
Wer? Wer ist das denn? Ah, Lorealerben. Okay. Ah ja. Okay, hab ich noch nie gehört. Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, Chat. Also es könnte sein, dass das Gehirn heute nicht ausreicht ohne nicht noch. Also mit zwei Subs mehr ist es durchaus möglich, dass wir das heute IQ-mäßig schaffen.
Ansonsten wird es kritisch. Dauert es alles viel länger, als ich gedacht habe.
Was nutzt du für ein OS in der VM? Ich benutze in der VM mal ein Jaro Linux. Das ist so ein Arch Linux Abkömmling. Arch, by the way. Und ja, gut, der Rest Windows.
Gut, der Chat will heute nicht, dann nicht. Mehr als dreimal Gbaiten kann ich nicht. Oh doch, jetzt kommt er noch. 30 Sekunden Zeit. Ich glaube, einen Sub brauchen wir noch.
Jawoll, wir haben es geschafft. Oh, ich dachte, Gbaitet uns mit 99%. Danke schön für die Subs. Flick. GP. 7 Monate. Green 4 Monate. Massive.
Schön Gbaiten lassen, Chef. Bisschen Geld überweisen. Danke für die Subs. Ich meine, ich kriege auch ein bisschen was. Zum Glück. Sonst würde ich das eigentlich gar nicht machen.
Jetzt wird den Sellout-Modus starten. So. Alles klar. Ja Leute, danke für die Subs. Also, wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, wir haben gerade nachgeguckt, wer die reichste Frau der Welt ist. Also mich juckt weder, wer der reichste Mann der Welt ist.
Das muss man heute immer dabei sagen. Ich wollte gerade sagen, mich juckt eigentlich gar nicht, wer die reichste Frau der Welt ist.
Aber in der heutigen Zeit ist das so. Wenn ich das so sage, dann gibt es schon wieder die ersten Leute, die sagen, Max, du bist frauenfeindlich.
Warum interessiert dich nicht, wer die reichste Frau der Welt ist? Deswegen muss man heutzutage dabei sagen.
Mich interessiert auch nicht, wer der reichste Mann der Welt ist. Und selbst dann können sich immer noch Leute aufregen.
Metzanin, danke schön für den Prime-Sub. Excellent. So. Um euch jetzt mal kurz zu erklären, was wir machen.
Übrigens, ich muss noch mal eine Sache einwerfen. Hat irgendjemand, ich will mich da nicht jetzt drüber auslassen.
Ich will euch nur mal fragen. Habt ihr diesen ZDF-Beitrag gesehen, wo es darum ging, dass auch Männer Feministen sein können?
Und dass Feminismus gut für Männer ist? Hat das zufällig jemand geguckt?
Also die haben da durchaus ein paar, finde ich, steile Thesen aufgestellt in dem Beitrag.
Die haben da echt schon ein paar steile Thesen aufgestellt. Aber ich will mich jetzt nicht darüber auslassen.
Bei manchen Sachen habe ich mir gedacht, na, da wäre ich mir aber mal nicht so sicher.
Schaut ihr mal Step-CA an. Step-CA sagt mir nichts. Was jetzt?
Ah, ich habe Firefox geupdatet. Ich muss Firefox aufstellen. Okay, easy.
Nein, nein, nein. Leute, wenn ihr den nicht gesehen habt, dann müsst ihr den auch nicht gucken.
Also man hat echt nichts verpasst, wenn man diesen Beitrag nicht gesehen hat.
Small Step-CA. Hab ich noch nie gehört. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Kann das forwarden? Kann das forwarden? Also kann das dann quasi...
Kann ich das lokal anfragen und das leite es dann weiter zu...
Macht dann für mich bei Cloudflare den externen DNS?
Weil ich meine, ich brauche hier immer noch irgendwelche gültigen Sachen.
Und das kann ich mir ja lokal schlecht gültig ausstellen.
Sodass mein Browser das Sache akzeptiert, es sei denn, ich importiere die CA.
Was genau bringt dir das Zertifikat gedönst lokal?
Naja, du hast ein Häkchen im Browser. Also ich finde das schon mal nicht schlecht.
Es hat übrigens auch ein paar weitere Vorteile.
Manche Browser erlauben mittlerweile gar nicht mehr bestimmte Sachen in nichts.
Also manche Browser, mit manche Browser meine ich Chrome.
Es gibt ja nicht so viele anderen, Firefox aber auch zunehmend.
Erlauben manche Sachen nicht, wenn die Seite nicht über HTTPS bereitgestellt wird.
Und dann auch nicht, wenn es kein gültiges Zertifikat hat.
Zum Beispiel manche WebRTC Sachen gehen nur mit HTTPS.
Spätestens wenn du eine PWA, also so eine App, die du auf den Homescreen hinzufügen kannst,
beim Smartphone benutzen willst, da gehen viele Sachen nur über HTTPS.
Und auch nur mit gültigem Zertifikat.
Und auch die ganzen Krypto-APs im Browser gehen auch nur, gerade was für Passwortmanager sicherlich nicht verkehrt ist,
gehen auch nur über HTTPS und nur mit gültigem Zertifikat.
Also ganz unsinnig ist das Ganze in der Tat nicht mittlerweile.
Außerdem ist es relativ einfach.
So und jetzt zeige ich euch mal was wir machen.
Also wir installieren, also wir machen das ja heute super, super furchtbar agil.
Das heißt wir machen auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Shit-Rebo.
Gibt es da nicht irgendeinen Workaround mit Fake-Zertifikaten?
Na ja, doch, doch, doch, doch, das kannst du machen solange das nicht überprüft wird.
Also was du machen kannst ist, du kannst dir ein eigenes Zertifikat lokal erstellen mit OpenSSL.
Dann musst du quasi die Stelle, die deine lokalen Zertifikate ausstellt, also die CA, die du dafür lokal benutzt,
musst du importieren oder musst das Zertifikat importieren und sagen, ich vertraue diesem Zertifikat.
Da gibt es verschiedene Sachen, wie man das machen kann.
Unter Windows geht es ein bisschen anders, also du kannst explizit sagen, ich vertraue diesem Zertifikat.
Ist alles okay, aber das klappt bei modernen Browsern auch teilweise nicht mehr.
Ich glaube mittlerweile sogar in Firefox und in Chrome, also die checken das, ob das von der gültigen CA ist.
Ja und zumal es auch gar nicht schwierig ist, gültige Zertifikate zu bekommen, das teile ich euch jetzt ja,
dass man da nicht allzu viel machen muss.
Also was man dazu braucht ist, man braucht eine gültige Domain.
Es ist eigentlich ziemlich egal, welche, aber man braucht eine gültige Domain.
Also ihr könnt entweder euch eine Domain kaufen oder ihr geht beispielsweise hier hin,
nicht Cloud DNS oder irgendwas und registriert euch da kostenlos irgendein Subdomain von denen.
Also es ist eigentlich vollkommen egal, aber ihr braucht eine eigene Domain, sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Man kann bei Hetzer eine Domain kaufen, du kannst bei jedem Cloud Registrar eine Domain kaufen.
Auch wenn ich bei Hetzer Sponsort bin, wobei bin ich ja gar nicht, wir haben ja nur ein Video gemacht.
Final ist ja die restliche Sache noch gar nicht, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich fand es über diese Hetzer Konsole nicht sonderlich angenehm, Domains zu bestellen.
Also da habe ich schon Besseres gesehen.
Zumindest ihr braucht eine Domain, die muss nichts kosten.
Ihr könnt eine kostenlose Domain nehmen, beispielsweise bei DuckDNS ist es egal.
Kann man auch eine Domain hernehmen, die man für einen Server benutzt.
Klar, du kannst alles nehmen.
Das einzige was du brauchst ist, das zeige ich euch jetzt ja gleich.
Das einzige was du brauchst ist eine Domain, wo du Zugriff auf den DNS hast,
für den das zuständig ist.
Das ist das einzige was du brauchst.
Wir nehmen eine Domain und zwar, wir nehmen nicht den Preis-Champ.
Oh, der Preis-Champ ist wieder kaputt.
Der kackt neuerdings echt alle zwei Tage mal ab.
Was soll denn das hier?
Kack weh, sagt er selbst schon.
Also wir nehmen die Domain, die ich mir registriert habe vor einer ganzen Weile.
Und das ist die hier.
Ich mache jetzt mal meinen Staubsauger auf, dann seht ihr die Domain.
Also hier, da.
Die habe ich mir schon vor einer ganzen Weile registriert.
Das ist meine Top-Level-Domain, das kostet auch nicht so viel.
Ach ja und falls jetzt jemand besonders schlau sein will.
Ohne Who ist Abfrage macht.
Dann werdet ihr feststellen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich sage es nur, weil sonst wieder irgendwelche Leute ankommen.
Max, leaked, Domain leaked, Adresse leaked, Telefonnummer leaked, Ansprechpartner, E-Mail-Adresse, alles leaked.
Nein, das ist nicht leaked.
Und selbst wenn ihr eine Anfrage stellen würdet, würde da nichts rauskommen.
Die Domain habe ich, glaube ich, registriert auf Peter Wubbel oder sowas.
Also da kriegt keiner irgendwie.
Zumindest nicht aus Versehen.
FBI, Polizei, wer auch immer, wenn sie wollen schon.
Aber warum sollten sie?
Aber ihr nicht.
Nein, nicht Peter Agile, den gab es damals noch nicht.
Ich glaube Peter Wubbel.
Ach, was auch immer.
Ist auch wurscht.
Der wohnt irgendwo, ich glaube, der wohnt an der Hauptwache in Frankfurt, der Typ.
Es gibt doch keine Haus-Top-Level-Domain.
Doch, gibt es.
Gibt es, kannst du dir kaufen, überhaupt kein Problem.
Es gibt eine Haus-Top-Level-Domain.
Kannst suchen.
Kannst suchen zum Beispiel nach ByteStrike.Haus.
Und die ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen schon was Timeout.
Vielleicht, weil ich es geblockt habe.
Ah ja.
Also ByteStrike.Haus ist ein True Name.
Was auch immer uns das sagen soll, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die kostet dich 10 Euro im ersten Jahr und 10 Dollar im ersten Jahr und 21 Dollar im zweiten Jahr.
Es gibt massig viele Domains.
Du kannst doch mal gucken, ob es ByteStrike.XXX gibt.
Wäre auch da.
Kostet aber schon 80 Euro im Jahr.
Übrigens, was ich ganz besonders toll finde, dass es Magenta.Gay gibt.
Das finde ich ja gut.
Wie unavailable.
Das letzte Mal stand noch da, dass ich mir die kaufen kann.
Wait a minute, warum ist Magenta.Gay?
Warum gibt es das nicht mehr?
Das letzte Mal habe ich geguckt, ob ich Magenta.Gay kaufen kann.
Ich hatte doch noch die Idee, wir machen ein Forum.
Wir machen da ein Forum drauf, wo sich die Leute über die Telekom beschweren können.
Ich rufe garantiert nicht Magenta.Gay im Stream auf.
Wie sieht es denn mit Vodafone aus?
2000 Euro im Jahr, das ist aber schon sportlich.
Gibt es Magenta.Suck?
Magenta.
Magenta.Suck.Org gibt es.
Kommen wir zur eigentlichen Sache zurück.
Es geht darum, Zertifikate auszustellen.
Das heißt, ihr braucht eine güllige Domain.
Es ist egal, ob ihr euch eine Domain kauft.
Übrigens Org ist relativ günstig.
D.E. ist günstig.
Es ist gar nicht so sehr, dass D.E. und K.O.M. großartig teuer wären.
D.E. und K.O.M. sind lustigerweise relativ günstig.
Ihr könnt euch beispielsweise eine D.O.M. kaufen für 9 Euro im Jahr.
Ich behaupte mal, es kann jeder sich heutzutage eine Domain leisten.
Ich meine 9 Euro im Jahr.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als ist das jetzt huge money.
Ich glaube, wenn man eine Domain haben will und sogar in Corona-Zeiten schafft man 9 Euro im Jahr.
Punkt EU.
Es ist letztendlich egal.
Es ist letztendlich egal, was ihr euch holt.
Ihr braucht eine Domain.
Ihr könnt euch auch hier eine kostenlose Domain holen.
Oder meinetwegen bei Strato oder so, falls noch irgendjemand Strato ernsthaft...
Gibt es überhaupt noch Leute, die Strato verinnern?
Ich habe da nur Pains-Champ-Erinnerungen an Strato.
Ionos ist 1 und 1.
Kommt dann Marcel Davis persönlich.
Das braucht ihr.
Ihr braucht eine gültige Domain.
Was man dann machen kann ist Folgendes.
Wenn ihr eine gültige Domain habt, habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch Zugriff auf den DNS-Server für diese Domain.
Um da Sachen einzustellen braucht man ja.
Sonst könnte man diese Domainer nicht verwenden.
Und wenn ihr das habt, dann könnt ihr Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge machen.
Striker95, danke für den Sub.
Na ja gut, jeder was er will.
Und dann könnt ihr Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge machen.
DNS-Challenge hat den Vorteil, der Server muss nicht im Internet stehen.
Die normale Let's Encrypt-Challenge für Zertifikate, da muss der Server von außen erreichbar sein.
Bei DNS-Challenges nicht.
So und das machen wir jetzt Ganze.
Ich habe im Vorfeld schon mal, also mein DNS ist bei Cloudflare.
Letztendlich ist es aber vollkommen egal, wo euer DNS ist.
Ihr könnt DuckDNS verwenden, ihr könnt irgendeinen x-beliebigen Domain-Registrat verwenden.
Ist egal.
Es hat den Vorteil, wenn es ein bisschen größer ist, weil dann wird es wahrscheinlich von den Plugins schon unterstützt.
Ihr müsst nichts von Hand machen.
Also ich habe mein DNS bei Cloudflare.
Ja ja, macht hier mal.
Ich lock mich da jetzt aber nicht ein.
Ich zeige es euch nur.
Ich habe keinen Bock wieder das Passwort zu leaken oder so, weil ich das letzte Mal schon fast geschafft habe.
Genau.
So und wenn man Cloudflare, sieht die DNS-Settings dann so aus.
Da kann man dann Sachen einstellen.
Und man kann bei Cloudflare API-Tokens generieren, dass man quasi auch automatisiert Einträge im DNS machen kann.
Das kann mittlerweile jeder größere DNS-Anbieter.
Das ist nichts besonderes.
Das können sie alle.
Und auch die meisten Domain-Registrare haben da mittlerweile API-Zugriff.
Also die Chancen sind höher einzufinden, der es nicht kann, als einen, der es kann.
So und dementsprechend kann man das alles automatisch machen.
Deswegen fangen wir jetzt mal an.
Also ihr braucht auf jeden Fall eine Domain.
Das ist das worauf ich raus wollte bei der ganzen Geschichte.
So und was wir jetzt...
Ups.
So und ich habe mir was überlegt.
Also was wir machen ist, wir machen ein Docker-Compose-File.
Da installieren wir ein Reverse-Proxy drauf, der für uns Zertifikat-Handling macht.
Das haben wir schonmal angeschnitten vor ein paar Streams.
Dann machen wir da ein Git-Frontend drauf.
Einfach weil es geht.
Und wir die Massive-Big-Brain, den Huge-Devops-Ansatz hier fahren.
Also das heißt, da wird alles ins Shit eingecheckt.
Das heißt, wir brauchen auch ein ordentliches Web-Interface dafür.
Und dann packen wir hier Vault-Warden drauf.
Strato-API bietet keine API für den DNS.
Ernsthaft?
Wirklich nicht?
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Strato-DNS-API.
Echt nicht?
Doch, guck hier.
Oder nicht?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Also, aber wenn Strato nicht kann, dann sagt Strato schonmal.
Bitte, Leute, können wir nicht einfach so anfangen?
Ja, das ist wie gesagt sowas ähnliches.
Genau, genau.
Wir haben ja sowas schonmal was Ähnliches gemacht im Stream.
Können wir nicht einfach anfangen ohne Daily-Scrum?
Oder Chat?
Oder sind wir sonst nicht agil genug?
Weekly.
Erstmal Sprintplanung machen.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir brauchen erstmal ganz wichtig.
Wir brauchen erstmal ein Kanban-Board.
Haben wir hier sowas?
Jurefix.
Moment, JetBrains hat ein Kanban-Board?
U-Track.
The fuck?
Die haben jetzt auch noch ein Ticket-System?
Das U-Track-Agile-Board.
Moment, ist das ein Ticket-System?
Oder ist das ein persönliches Zeit-Man?
Nee, nee, nee.
Was ist das?
Wie funktioniert das?
Das hat aber keine Jira-Anbindung, oder?
Gibt es schon länger.
Ich kenne das nicht.
Aber Agile und JetBrains.
Wir müssen jetzt mal anfangen, sonst wird das heute nichts.
Ihr wisst, 22 Uhr muss ich ins Bett.
Bin ich müde.
Man kann Jira importieren.
Man müsste einen permanenten SYNC haben, dass das geht.
Okay, wir haben jetzt unsere Kanban-Boards rumgeschrieben.
Aktuelle Sprintplanung gemacht.
Und CI-CD-Pipeline aufgesetzt.
Und jetzt kann es losgehen.
Gut.
Also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das hier auf der Kiste mache oder ob ich das
auf dem Raspberry Pi machen soll.
Endlich ist es egal.
Wir machen das so.
Ich mache es hier auf der Kiste und dann zeige ich euch, wie einfach man das auf dem Raspberry
Pi umziehen kann, ohne dass man was machen muss wirklich.
Also, wenn ich es hier auf der Kiste mache, ist es auch einfacher.
Da muss ich auf meinem Router keine DNS-Settings-Einstellungen machen oder sowas.
Also, wir machen mal ein Verzeichnis.
Keck-wait.
Mist.
Zum Glück habe ich Keck-wait genannt.
Das Verzeichnis gab es schon.
Was ist denn da drin?
Nix.
Na, das ist ja gut.
Gut, dass ich so schöne Verzeichnisse habe.
So.
Und darin legen wir jetzt einen Pfeil an, bevor ich den Chat wieder triggere, dass ich
das mit Vim aufmache.
Wir können das auch nachher gerne mit Visual Studio Code bearbeiten, ja.
Weil ich weiß, sonst sagt der erste schon wieder, Vim, Painschamp, ich benutze Nano.
Und dann muss ich wieder den Leuten sagen, man sollte kein Nano benutzen.
Nano ist für Noobs.
Nur Noobs verwenden Nano.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die Noobs machen.
Das erste ist, Noobs verwenden Nano.
Und das zweite ist, Noobs fliegen den Heli.
Die zwei Sachen.
Das sind zwei Sachen, die sollte man einfach nicht machen.
Okay, also.
TouchDockerCompose.YAML.
So, natürlich sind wir super agil.
Und agil bedeutet, wir machen das alles in Linux-Container.
An der Stelle, man muss das nicht machen, ja.
Also, man kann das auch alles von Hand installieren und konfigurieren auf einem Debian, auf einem Raspberry Pi.
Das ist kein Ding.
Es hat aber den Vorteil, und das werdet ihr, denke ich, jetzt auch mal sehen.
Es ist schon eine ganze Ecke nachvollziehbarer, was passiert.
Und man kann die Konfig in ein Git-Repo einchecken, auf ein anderes Server kopieren,
Docker Compose ausführen, und es ist genau wieder alles da.
Das hat schon seinen Vorteil.
Ich schreibe übrigens absichtlich YAML anstatt YIML.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Leute, Umfrage.
Moment, Umfrage, Umfrage.
Prediction.
Nee, nicht Prediction.
Prediction können wir nicht machen.
Was soll man da predikten?
Okay, Frage, YAML versus YAML.
YAML versus YAML.
Dauer eine Minute reicht.
Nee, zusätzliche Sachen mit Bits lohnt sich jetzt nicht.
Okay, so.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist YAML überhaupt?
Ein relativ gut lesbares Textformat für Konfig-Files.
Ja, das kommt auf das Projekt, aber normalerweise sollte das kein großartiges Problem sein.
Chat macht 50-50.
Ich bin schon, ich bin nicht mehr im verbreiteten Lager.
Ich persönlich mach Punkt YAML.
Obwohl, es ist ziemlich knapp.
48-52.
Es ist 50-50, kann man sagen.
YAML ist zu lang.
YAML hat gewonnen.
Ja, okay.
Aber ich schreib's trotzdem mit YAML.
Okay, also die meisten verwenden YAML.
Komm, wir machen es mit Visual Studio Code auf.
Guck mal, der erkennt sogar, dass das ein Docker-Compose-File ist.
Remind me later.
Jetzt will sich das Ding erst mal 30 Minuten aktualisieren.
Ist beides denn offiziell?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Seit Ruby-Zeiten verwende ich YAML.
Ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, dass unter der alten Ruby on Rails-Version das Zeug wirklich Punkt YAML heißen musste.
So.
Gut, jetzt können wir den Kram zumachen.
Also, das wird jetzt unser Text-Datei, in der wir reinschreiben, welche Services wir starten wollen und wie wir die Services konfigurieren wollen.
Und nein, ich mach das nicht komplett aus dem Kopf.
Ich bescheiße heute ein bisschen.
Ich guck das ab von meiner YAML-Datei, die ich bei mir hier auf der Kiste laufen hab.
Aber die kann ich euch nicht reinkopieren, weil da sind Passwörter und sowas drinne.
Das muss nicht sein.
Aber ich guck ein bisschen ab.
Hat ja keiner was davon, wenn das alles lange dauert.
Okay, also das erste, was man machen muss, man muss eine Version reinschreiben.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was die aktuelle Version ist von Docker Compose.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Ja, ja, ich hab alles in einem Docker Compose-File.
Passwort.
Nee, das stimmt gar nicht.
Meine API-Keys hab ich da nicht drinne.
Da hab ich einen extra Secret-File für.
Okay, hier haben wir 3.8.
Ich bleib mal bei 3.3, weil da weiß ich, dass alle Optionen, die ich verwende, auch funktionieren.
Kann man Version 3 machen, dann nimmt das neueste.
Geht das?
Das hab ich noch nie probiert.
Letztendlich wurscht.
Also das erste, was wir jetzt machen ist, wir testen jetzt erstmal, ob der Kram an sich funktioniert.
Du hast bestimmt nicht von Chia gehört, oder?
Ich hab was von Chico gehört.
Das ist meine Katze.
Wer ist Chia?
Chia.
Oder Chaya.
Das ist bestimmt nicht ein YouTube-Drama, oder?
Von dem ich mit nichts mitgekriegt hab.
Oder du meinst China.
Die chinesischen China-Chinesen.
Ach, Kryptowährung, doch.
Davon hab ich schon mal was gehört.
Das ist die Storage-Coin.
Sorry for bash.
Excellent.
Zwei Monate Subscription.
Übrigens, sorry, falls ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen hab.
Ich guck nachher nochmal rein.
Okay, wir fangen jetzt erstmal an.
Leute, guck mal, guck mal.
Es ist 20.30 Uhr.
Bis spätestens 22 Uhr.
Stichtag, oder?
Hört man das?
Stichtzeit?
Also wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen was auf die Reihe kriegen.
Nee, wobei ich muss...
Nee, das stimmt gar nicht.
Ich kann ruhig eine halbe Stunde länger aufbleiben heute, oder eine Stunde.
Das ist kein Ding.
Aber ich bin meistens müde, wenn ich halt einen Tag gearbeitet hab.
So, also.
Als erstes muss man eine Versionsdatei reinschreiben.
Muss man eine Version reinschreiben?
Ansonsten Spackzrupp.
Muss sein.
Fragt mich nicht.
So, wollen wir uns jetzt nicht so lange aufhalten?
Also, wir testen jetzt erstmal, ob das funktioniert.
Und dazu machen wir folgendes.
Wo geht's denn hier los?
Genau.
Also.
Services.
Guck mal, der macht sogar Einrückung für mich.
Excellent.
Services.
Wir starten jetzt einmal in den Testcontainer, um zu gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Dann gibt's einen schönen Testcontainer dafür.
Der nennt sich Who Am I?
Und der Standard Who Am I Container ist aber eigentlich ein anderer.
Weil es ist letztendlich wurscht, wurscht, was man nimmt.
Ich glaub, der Standard Who Am I Container ist irgendwas mit Continuous oder so.
Ja, der da.
Aber ist egal, das ist ein Hallo Welt Container.
Also, das ist quasi das Gegenstück zur Hallo Welt.
Ich kopier mir das jetzt einfach mal.
Also, wir starten jetzt erstmal in den Testcontainer.
So.
Image, Name, das da.
Und dann machen wir noch Container.
Hat man eigentlich Autocomplete hier in Visual Studio Code?
Nee, ne?
So.
Container, Name, Who Am I?
Mehr muss man erstmal nicht machen.
Wenn wir den Testcontainer laufen haben, dann können wir ausprobieren, dass wir da ein
gültiges Zertifikat dafür bekommen.
Das ist quasi mehr oder weniger...
Das ist nicht der offizielle Hallo World Container, aber sowas ähnliches.
Weiß jemand, wie ich auf Linux Bin-Datei installiere?
Ja.
Du machst ein chmod plus x auf die Bin-Datei.
Und danach machst du blub.bin.
Und wenn das dann ausführbar ist, dann kannst du es ausführen.
Echt?
Es gibt einen Completion Plugin für Docker Compose?
Zeig es mal her.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Docker Compose.
Compose.
Was muss ich denn da suchen?
Nee, das hat eine Kackbewertung.
Warte mal.
Hier?
Nee, das ist das normale Docker.
Moment, das ist das normale Docker Plugin.
Das bringt doch nichts, oder?
Außerdem ist es der wishlist...
Nee.
Echt?
Braucht man die normale Docker-Extension?
Wie kann das?
Das...
Daubt das im Chat hier.
Leute, wenn man zu viel Twitch-Chat guckt.
Ja.
Niemand, der noch halbwegs bei Sinnen ist.
Und gar keiner, der 36 ist.
Nutzt das Wort Daubt das, Alter.
Daubt das im Chat, Alter.
Okay, die Microsoft-Docker-Extension soll mich interessieren.
Ehrlich, daubt das.
Okay, so, komm mal her.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob der Chat recht hat.
Wir könnten eine Prediction machen.
Hat der Chat recht?
Und dann ist die nächste Frage...
Also, wenn der Chat nicht recht hat, ist die Frage,
gebadet der Chat einfach nur oder weiß es der Chat nicht besser?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was besser ist.
So, jetzt haben wir das installiert.
Jetzt muss man es nochmal neu aufmachen.
Und jetzt sagt der Chat, habe ich Autocomplete
in meinem Docker-Compose-File.
Ach so, ich sollte vielleicht die Datei aufmachen.
Das verzeichne ich nochmal auf.
So.
Habe ich jetzt Autocomplete?
Tatsächlich.
Ich habe Autocomplete.
Der Chat hat recht.
Sachen gibt es.
Okay, der Chat hat recht.
Ich muss einen Sub giften.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie man random Sub gifte.
Wie giftet man random Sub?
Nee.
Wie geht denn das?
Gift random Sub Twitch.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Wie macht man das?
Wie gifte man random Sub?
Gift Sub.
Ach, ich weiß, warum ich das nicht sehe.
Das habe ich ausgeblendet.
Das habe ich ausgeblendet in FFZ.
Ich habe alles ausgeblendet.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Hammer gleich, Hammer gleich.
Ich mache einfach die Erweiterung kurz aus.
Okay.
Abo verschenken.
Seid refresh.
Abo, Abo verschenken.
Okay.
Dieses Abo unterstützt direkt Wubblors und den Stream von Wubblors.
Also wenn ich selbst ein Abo, also wenn ich selbst ein Abo gifte, dann unterstützt das nur Jeff und sonst keinen.
Okay, mal gucken, wer Glück hat.
Mal gucken, wer Glück hat.
Wer hat Glück?
Der Canetus.
Nice.
Der hat auch ein schönes Emote.
Das mag ich.
Das hat der Richtige gekriegt.
Guck, Canetus hier.
Pepo Happy.
Wahrscheinlich Lurker im Chat guckt irgendwie drei Stunden oder so mal wieder ins Stream rein und kriegt gar nicht mit, dass er einen Sub gegiftet bekommt.
Was?
Lurkers und Daubters heute wieder.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Also ich hab festgestellt, wir haben tatsächlich, was laber ich denn, wir haben Autocomplete.
Gut, da wollte ich nicht drauf raus.
Also wir haben jetzt einen Hello World Test Container.
Und wenn der jetzt geht, machen wir das mit den Zertifikaten.
Also gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Docker, Compose, ab.
Der sollte jetzt nichts anderes machen, wie den Hello World Container starten.
Der Vorteil davon ist...
Network Cagweight Default.
Warum?
Also was ich sagen wollte, also man sieht den prinzipiellen Vorteil davon schon.
Ich kann das jetzt Copy Pasten auf einen anderen Rechner und eins zu eins so starten.
Aber warum startet er denn nicht?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Was soll uns das jetzt sagen?
Ich mein, das ist ja nicht der erste Docker Container, den wir hier starten.
Nee, nee, das reicht.
Also mehr musst du da eigentlich nicht einstellen normalerweise.
Was ist denn das Problem jetzt?
Was? Das kenne ich noch nicht.
Also wenn ich dafür Sudon muss, dann habe ich was verkackt mit meinen Berechtigungen.
Nee, weil ich habe berechtigt.
Fail to create endpoint?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich gebe das doch 3.3 an.
Was?
Was ist das? Den Fehler habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Peer Interfaces, Operation not supported.
Ach, ich weiß woran das liegt.
Wisst ihr woran das liegt?
Ich habe ein Update gemacht, da war ein Kernel Update dabei.
Ja, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Reboot, bam.
Also nach dem Reboot müsste es eigentlich wieder funktionieren.
Reboot Champ, ja.
Das ist das offizielle Hello World Image, das bringt uns aber nicht, weil ich brauche ein Netzwerk Hello World Image.
Mal gucken, ob die Daub das Recht haben, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Ab.
Hat gestartet, exzellent, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Daub das haben nicht recht.
So, also, gehen wir mal dahin.
Curl, Port 80.
Ach so, ich habe ja keinen Load Balancer davor, da kann das ganz natürlich nicht funktionieren.
Bei.
Sollte ich dann mich 80 80 nehmen?
Wenn es frei ist.
Man kann den, also man könnte den Port angeben, aber hätte fast gesagt, das sollte machte automatisch.
Aber wenn nicht, dann geben wir den Port an.
Letztendlich brauchen wir das eh nicht.
Aber der gleiche Load Balancer davor machen.
Kann man das so machen?
Erst mal hier exzellent experimentieren, stellts.
Port 80 so.
Ah, jetzt hat er irgendwas weitergeleitet.
Okay, und jetzt machen wir Port 80 auf Port 80 oder Port irgendwas auf so.
Und dann macht er das Ganze richtig.
Jawoll, okay, Curl.
Also, das ist die Antwort von unserem Container hier.
Das meine ich, das ist quasi so ein Minimal Container, der einfach den User Agent zurückgibt, der aufgerufen hat mit der IP.
Also da gibt es das Ding Großartiges.
Dazu zu sagen, das ist ein guter Test Container, ob alles funktioniert.
Und man hat gerade gesehen, er hat seinen Zweck hier auch erfüllt, weil der Test hat nicht funktioniert.
Linus Torvalds On-White Desktop Linux Sachs.
Ne, das kenne ich noch nicht, aber das ist die Debian-Config von 2014.
Das ist uralt.
Oder? Ist das was Neues?
Das sieht von der Aufnahme her so relativ alt aus.
Und ja, er hat wahrscheinlich sogar heute immer noch recht, weil der Linux Desktop das sagt.
Und ich bin fast der Meinung, dass der Linux Desktop heute sogar mehr sagt als 2014.
Weil so coole Projekte wie Compets und sowas damals am Start waren, die total eingeschlafen sind.
Compets war für mich so die Zukunft des Linux Desktops.
Gut, machen wir aber weiter. Okay, unser Test Container funktioniert.
Wir können das nachher nochmal gucken, wenn wir Zeit haben.
Erinnert mich, mach das mal auf.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat er recht, geht ja nur 11 Minuten, gucken wir nachher an.
So, also, jetzt kümmern wir uns erstmal um die Zertifikate, dass wir gültige Zertifikate bekommen.
So, also ihr seht, wir haben einen Container, lokal laufen, Port 80.
Und wenn ich den aufrufe, dann kriege ich halt eine Antwort, dass ich da HTTP drüber machen kann.
Reicht, schmeißen wir hier raus. So, und jetzt die Frage, wie machen wir das mit den Zertifikaten?
Also Zertifikate holen wir uns natürlich von Let's Encrypt.
So, und es gibt zwei Sachen, wie man Let's Encrypt verwenden kann.
Also Let's Encrypt ist, ich versuche das mal kurz ganz schnell zu erklären für Leute, die das noch nicht kennen oder nichts damit gemacht haben.
Also Let's Encrypt ist eine Stelle, die vergibt Zertifikate.
Davon gibt es jede Menge, zum Beispiel Veri-Sign, Komodo und so, die übrigens teilweise schon ihre Keys geklaut.
War Komodo nicht das, die die Keys geklaut bekommen haben?
Steal oder sowas?
Breach?
War das Komodo? Vielleicht weiß noch jemand. Also entweder war das Symantec, kann auch sein.
Ist auch egal, es gibt schon lange Stellen, die Zertifikate ausstellen.
Zertifikate ist im Prinzip das, was hier dahinter steckt, dass euer Browser sagt, das ist eine gültige HTTPS-Verbindung und die Connection ist secure und ein grünes Häkchen dran.
Und die kosten aber alle Geld und teilweise auch nicht so wenig.
Let's Encrypt ist die erste Zertifizierungsstelle, die kostenlos Zertifikate rausgibt, die gültig sind, weil das Erstellen von Zertifikaten ist nicht das Problem.
Jeder kann sich selbst hier mit OpenSSL im Terminal Zertifikate erstellen.
Das wichtige ist, dass die Stelle, die die Zertifikate rausgibt, also die es euch signiert mit ihrem Schlüssel,
dass dieser Stelle, die die Zertifikate rausgibt, von den Browser-Herstellern vertraut wird, weil nur dann gibt es ein grünes Häkchen.
Ansonsten gibt es diese Meldungen, die ihr alle schon mal gesehen habt, hier mit rotem, orangischem Fenster, Achtung, Warning, falsches Zertifikat.
Nur wenn der Browser der Sachen vertraut.
Let's Encrypt ist die erste Zertifizierungsstelle, denen alle Browser vertrauen, die Zertifikate kostenlos ausstellt.
Es gibt jetzt ein paar Leute, unter anderem bei mir auch auf der Arbeit, die argumentieren dann damit und sagen,
ja, das ist kostenlos, da bringen die Leute der Sache nicht so viel Vertrauen entgegen.
Ganz im Ernst, meiner persönlichen Meinung nach, ist es dem End-User, um es jetzt mal etwas energischer auszudrücken,
der End-User gibt einen absoluten Fick drauf, von welcher Zertifizierungsstelle dieses Zertifikat ausgestellt ist.
Hauptsache es ist ein grüner Haken dran. Der Rest ist dem User vollkommen egal und sie wissen es auch gar nicht.
Also wichtig ist dem User, dass es hier ein grünes Häkchen gibt oder ein Schloss, das interessiert den User.
Sonst ist dem eigentlich alles vollkommen egal. Und wie Let's Encrypt das macht, da kann sich ja keiner hinsetzen und wirklich euren Antrag überprüfen,
wie Let's Encrypt das macht, ist, die checken einfach, ob die Domain, für die ihr das Zertifikat ausstellen wollt, euch gehört.
Und wie machen die das? Die gehen davon aus, wenn ihr Admin seid, also auf dem DNS-Server, der für diese Domain zuständig ist,
dann seid ihr der Eigentümer der Domain. Also sprich, wenn euch einer euren Account klaut, dann ist er ja quasi aus Let's Encrypt-Sicht auch Eigentümer der Domain.
Also ihr müsst quasi Let's Encrypt beweisen, dass ihr die Domain, dass euch die Domain gehört.
Und das macht ihr damit, dass ihr quasi Let's Encrypt beweisen könnt, hey, ich habe Admin-Rechte auf dem DNS, der für die Domain zuständig ist.
Und ihr müsst dann dort auf dem DNS einen geheimen Key hinterlegen, oder was heißt ein geheimen Key?
Ihr müsst einen Key hinterlegen und Let's Encrypt schaut, ob dieser Key dort ist.
Wenn dieser Key dort ist, bedeutet das, weil es ein random Key ist, ihr müsst den da hinterlegt haben.
Und weil ihr nur Admin-Rechte habt auf eurem DNS, seid ihr der rechtmäßige Besitzer der Domain. Also das ist der Sinn dahinter.
So, man kann das von Hand machen, das machen wir vielleicht auch mal in einem Stream irgendwann. Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate wirklich Schritt für Schritt von Hand.
Aber eigentlich möchte man das nicht von Hand machen, diese Let's Encrypt-Challenge-Sache, weil Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate gelten bloß drei Monate.
Und da muss man sie erneuern. Solange es automatisch geht, ist das kein Problem, wenn man das von Hand macht, zack, das.
Deswegen gibt es total viele Hilfstools dafür, um Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate auszustellen.
Das bekannteste dürfte Third-Bot sein. Hat wahrscheinlich auch schon der eine oder andere gesehen.
Was ist denn das? Achso, das ist die offizielle Seite drauf, der war ich noch nie drauf.
Also eines der bekanntesten Sachen ist wahrscheinlich Third-Bot.
Und da, das ist ein Kommando... Hallo? Shithub? Sieht's aus.
Das ist ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool, mit dem ich Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate mir ausstellen lassen kann.
Hat auch den Nachteil, ich muss immer noch dafür sorgen, dass ich das alle drei Monate ausführe oder dass das alle drei Monate automatisch ausgeführt wird. Ist alles nicht so schön.
Viel schöner wäre es, wenn wir einfach den Service starten könnten in unserem Docker-Compose-File, was alles das für uns handelt.
Und da gibt's... Warum soll ich Visual Studio restarten? Nee, mach ich jetzt nicht.
So, und da gibt's einige Dinger. Ja, es gibt zig Third-Bot-Container, es gibt zig Nginx-Container, es gibt Caddy-Container, es gibt Traffic-Container, was auch immer.
Gibt's total viele Sachen. Und ich verwende da halt jetzt mal einen davon, um das zu machen.
Weil neben gültigen Zertifikaten brauchen wir ja noch was.
Ein gültiges Zertifikat alleine bringt uns gar nichts. Wir brauchen noch einen Eingang für unsere Services.
Also sprich, ich hab ja in der Regel den Raspberry Pi zum Beispiel irgendwo stehen. Der Raspberry Pi hat eine IP-Adresse.
Ich hab aber vielleicht 30 Domains. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie einen Web-Server da drauf haben, der das handeln kann.
Also sprich, eine IP mit 50 Domains. Das geht, ist gar kein Problem. Du brauchst aber einen Web-Server davor.
Das heißt, wir verwenden einen Web-Server, den man dann auch Reverse-Proxy nennt an der Stelle.
Der macht für uns das Zertifikatzeug und der dient gleichzeitig als Gateway zu unseren Services.
Dann nehmen wir heute mal Traffic. Traffic ist von der Konfig her ziemlich trash.
Um es mal nett zu sagen. Also die Traffic-Konfig ist wirklich massive, also richtig trashig.
Aber das Schöne ist, dass man Traffic relativ easy konfigurieren kann, um Docker-Container automatisch zu Reverse-Proxys und dafür Zertifikate abzurufen.
Das heißt, solange man Traffic nur mit Docker-Containern verwendet, ist es ziemlich geil und relativ easy.
Dann lieber Apache. Apache ist ja die painst-champigste Lösung von allen, um das da zu machen.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich verwende am liebsten Caddy für einfache Sachen und Engine X für kompliziertere Sachen.
Aber Traffic für kleine Docker-Setups ist auch wunderbar.
Kannst du aus dem Stream auch ein Video machen? Ja, es ist ja im Archiv dann drin.
Ach guck mal, er hat's erkannt. Ich sag doch, sag doch irgendwie Lurker, der drei Stunden später wiederkommt.
Ich hab Random-Sub gegiftet. Ich hab Random-Sub gegiftet und du hast gewonnen.
Jetzt kannst du exzellente, exzellente Emotes verwenden hier.
Dann legen wir das Ganze mal an und bei der Gelegenheit kann ich euch nochmal eine Sache zeigen, die wichtig ist für Container- und Docker-Compose-Setups.
Und zwar, wir nehmen mal den da. Weiß gar nicht, ob das Tags hat. Also worauf man achten muss bei allen möglichen Container-Setups,
ist auf die Version von den, es ist nicht die Container-Version, das trifft es nicht genau, aber ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal so, auf die Version.
Denn, wenn ich hier, also es gibt einen Tag, den gibt es überall, der nennt sich Latest. Latest ist immer die aktuellste Version, die zuletzt veröffentlicht wurde.
Das ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt das, was man haben will. Und wenn ich dieses Docker, also wenn ich hier überall Latest reinschreibe,
bei meinen Containern und ich kopiere das Docker-File jetzt beispielsweise auf einen anderen Rechner und will das starten, dann kann es sein, dass ich dort eine neue Version bekomme, die ich vielleicht gar nicht haben will.
Oder wenn ich update oder meine recreaten lasse, meine Container, was auch immer, dann bekomme ich neue Versionen, die ich nicht haben will und die vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr zu meinen Config-Files passen und sowas.
Hast du schon mit Docker-Alternativen Potman gearbeitet? Ja, wir haben Potman auf der Arbeiten, der macht mehr Probleme, als dass es schön ist.
Wir haben zum Beispiel einen DovCon laufen bei uns im Docker-Container, weil die Red Hat-Version so alt ist und es ist heute Nacht erstmal schön kaputt gegangen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum. Ich weiß nur, dass ich über das normale System die Unit-File nicht mal gestartet bekommen habe.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe mit Potman viel mehr Probleme als mit Docker bisher. Und ich verstehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, wo der Riesen-Scharme bei Potman ist.
Ja, ich weiß, der Haupt-Selling-Point bei Potman ist, dass man das nicht alles gut laufen lassen muss. Aber wenn man den Kram dafür verwendet, wofür er gedacht ist, für irgendwelche lokalen Dev-Setups oder für irgendwelche lokalen Setups.
Naja, da ist es jetzt nicht so schlimm.
So, wo waren wir denn? Wir waren bei Container-Versionen.
Genau, also wie gesagt, wenn man sowas hier anlegt, man sollte eine Version reinschreiben, auf die man sich verlassen kann. So, wir gucken jetzt mal Beispiel 2. Alter, was ist denn das für...
Was ist mit der Seide los? Ach, das ist mein Dark-Reader. Das ist der Dark-Reader, der hier rumspackt.
Der Dark-Reader. So, wir gucken mal, was es hier für Versionen gibt. Es gibt anscheinend hier...
Versionstag V2.4. Das klingt schon mal gut. Das nehmen wir. Man muss sich jemals angucken, wie die jeweiligen Projekte das versionieren.
Meistens ist das so. Also, nicht immer, aber meistens. Es gibt immer einen Latest-Tag. Das zeigt einfach auf die letzte veröffentlichte Version.
Und dann machen die meisten noch einen ganz konkreten Version-Tag. Sowas wie Version 2.4.8. Das heißt, wenn ihr das ausführt, bekommt ihr immer Version 2.4.8.
Und dann, was die meisten Projekte noch machen, ist, sie machen so einen Major-Minor-Version-Tag. Das heißt, wenn ihr diesen Tag hier reinschreibt, dann bekommt ihr immer Version 2.4, aber immer die neueste Version 2.4.
Also, ihr bekommt in dem Fall hier auch Version 2.4.8, aber, sobald 2.4.9 veröffentlicht wurde, bekommt ihr 2.4.9, wenn ihr updatet. Oder Container recreated.
Also, das ist eigentlich so meine bevorzugte Variante, weil innerhalb von so einer Major-Minor-Kombination funktionieren die meisten Sachen eigentlich weiterhin.
Also, das ist ganz sinnvoll, sowas da reinzuschreiben. So, also, sagen wir Image. Image, äh, was ist denn das richtige Image für Traffic?
Vielleicht heißt es einfach nur Traffic, ok. Traffic, so, jetzt brauchen wir Version 2.4.
2.4 und kleiner 2.5, das kann man auch machen. So, jetzt kriegen wir nur diese Version und, äh, Security-Fixes dafür oder was auch immer, die da rausbringen.
Willst du kurz, äh, Symantec Versioning? Nee, will ich nicht. So, ähm, jetzt haben wir schon mal zwei Container.
Ein Load-Balancer oder sagen wir ein Reverse-Proxy, der sich um Zertifikate kümmert und einen Container, den wir ansprechen, einen Service, den wir von außen ansprechen können. So, jetzt müssen wir dem Ding natürlich noch sagen, hey, Load-Balancer mal oder, oder besser gesagt, äh, mach mal Zertifikate, mach mal Reverse-Proxy.
Das Slash ist doch falsch, du hast recht, das muss ein Doppelpunkt sein. So, ähm, und dazu muss man dem Ding jetzt ein paar Kommandos mitgeben.
Das wäre ich jetzt.
Das, äh, gut, aber ohne, ohne, ohne, äh, Moment, nee, nee, nee, das geht so. Da muss ich nichts davor machen. Nee, brauch ich nichts davor. Wir könnten auch die, wir könnten auch die GitHub-Container-Registry nehmen.
Zumindest muss ich dem jetzt erstmal sagen, was er machen soll. Und ich werde das jetzt mal kopieren, Zeile für Zeile, weil ich keinen Bock hab, das alles einzutippen.
Ähm, wir geben, wir geben dem Container ein paar Kommandos mit. Und zwar erstmal, dass er Debug-Ausgabe machen soll. Das kann man, kann man eigentlich immer machen, solange man am Konfigurieren ist.
Dann sieht man besser, was kaputt geht, wenn was kaputt geht. So. Dann sagen wir dem, hey, du sollst alle Docker, oder du sollst dich für Docker-Container zuständig fühlen.
Als nächstes sagen wir ihm, ok, alle anderen Container, die in diesem, in diesem File definiert sind.
Wobei, es, es betrifft auch mehr, aber, bleiben wir jetzt mal, also, für alle anderen Container, die wir hier definieren, sollst du automatisch Zertifikate dir besorgen und die, äh, Proxien.
Das heißt, wir müssen dann nicht bei jedem Container was hinschreiben. So. Jetzt die nächsten zwei Sachen. Ist auch noch relativ selbsterklärend.
Ähm, wir wollen, dass das Ding auf Port 80 läuft und auf Port 443.
Ist insofern ganz sinnvoll, auf Port 80 ist halt normales HTTP und dementsprechend können wir dann alle Anfragen, die auf HTTP reinkommen, automatisch umleiten auf HTTPS, sofern HTTPS gewünscht ist für den jeweiligen Container.
So, und das nächste muss ich jetzt mal copy-pasten. Äh, weil das die, weil das die wichtigen Sachen sind. So.
Genau. Also die zwei Sachen braucht man, wenn man DNS-Challenge machen will. Wie gesagt, es gibt die zwei Sachen, dass es über den Webserver geht oder über DNS-Challenge, nachdem wir das ganze lokal betreiben wollen, wollen wir Let's Encrypt DNS-Challenge machen.
Hier muss man eben sagen, hey, ich will DNS-Challenge verwenden und nicht HTTP-Challenge. Und hier muss ich eben sagen, was ich für einen DNS-Anbieter verwenden will.
Also sprich, wenn ihr zum Beispiel DuckDNS verwendet, da wäre das DuckDNS und wenn ihr Cloudflare verwendet, wäre das Cloudflare. Und wenn ihr Namecheap oder was es noch alles gibt verwendet, dann müsst ihr da den jeweiligen Anbieter eintragen bzw. Namen von dem Plugin, was den jeweiligen Anbieter unterstützt.
In der Regel ist es der gleiche Name wie der Anbieter. So. Und jetzt ist das Ding konfiguriert und er weiß, ok, ich soll Zertifikate ausstellen. Es funktioniert aber noch nicht so ganz.
Als erstes müssen wir noch mal einstellen, dass das Ding an Port 80 auf Port 80 weiterleitet. Port 443 auf Port 443 weiterleitet. So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob ich noch was einstellen muss. Genau.
Ich muss ihm Zugriff geben auf meinen anderen Docker-Container. Sonst funktioniert der ganze Spaß nicht, weil sonst kann er sich die Informationen nicht holen, was es noch für Docker-Container gibt.
So. Und jetzt kommt das große Passwort-Leak, Leute. Das massive große Passwort-Leak. Und ihr müsst es nicht ausprobieren, weil ich habe Cloudflare gesagt, dass es nur von meiner Absender-IP geht, aber ok.
Checkweight. Aber ich leake hier jetzt. Achtung. Huge Leak. Da muss ich jetzt nämlich noch sagen, ok, wenn du DNS-Challenge bei Cloudflare machen willst, naja, mit welchem User und mit welchem Passwort sollen wir das dann machen?
So. Und das sagt man eben so. Also sprich, er soll als Cloudflare-DNS-IP-Token das Ding verwenden. Ist Cloudflare ein einfacher... Sekunde. Ist Cloudflare ein einfacher DNS-Hoster oder bietet das gratis Abo da mehr als ein klassischer DNS-Zone? Was? Hä? Moment.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was es mehr bietet. Also du kannst... Du kannst mit dem... Also mit dem Paid-Abo hast du mehr Möglichkeiten, was DDoS-Protection angeht. Das weiß ich. Das schreiben sie auch überall ganz fett.
Du hast mehr Optionen, was Analytics angeht. Also Besucher auf Seiten und bla und sonst was. Du kannst, glaube ich, mehr mit Workern machen. Aber ansonsten, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung... Ach ja, doch, klar. Du kannst mit dem Paid-Abo bei Cloudflare, glaube, diesen...
Diesen Redirect, also dass das durch Cloudflare geht, kannst du, glaube ich, noch auf anderen Ports machen als die Default-Ports. Irgendwie sowas. Ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, was du da mit mir kannst.
Aber nee, das ist ziemlich easy. Du stellst deine DNS-Server beim Domain-Registrar, wenn du nicht direkt bei Cloudflare registriert hast, auf Cloudflare ein und dann machst du alles da über die DNS-AP.
Und ja, übrigens das hier, das Passwort hier im Klartext reinschreiben, beziehungsweise das Token im Klartext reinschreiben, kann man machen, muss man nicht. Man kann auch Secrets-Files verwenden. Also dann könnte man ein extra Secrets-Abschnitt hier oben anlegen und da sagen, hey, in Wirklichkeit steht das Passwort in der anderen Datei drinne.
Machen wir jetzt nicht, wir Hardcoden das. Wie gesagt, ich hab das eh eingeschränkt auf eine Domain und mit meiner aktuellen Absender-IP.
So, also jetzt haben wir das Cloudflare-DNS-AP-Token. Das heißt, jetzt kann das Teil Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate ausstellen. Das war's. Mehr müssen wir erstmal nicht konfigurieren.
Bei Traffic, wobei doch, wir können noch zwei Sachen machen und zwar Copy-Paste ich mir jetzt mal, dass der Redirected ohne mir das näher anzugucken.
Das hab ich einfach aus meiner anderen Datei kopiert. Dass der Redirected HTTP automatisch auf HTTPS ist. Ok, wunderbar. Jetzt können wir das Ganze starten.
Und jetzt kriegen wir ein gültiges Zertifikat gleich für diesen Container. Jetzt müssen wir dem noch sagen, was dieser Container für eine Domain bekommen soll.
Dedos Schutz ist dabei, aber du bekommst mehr Möglichkeiten mit dem Paid-Abo.
Zum Beispiel ist die Detection, dass es automatisch anspringt und so besser. Die lassen sich das schon ganz gut bezahlen, weil es ist eigentlich die Hauptsache, mit dem Cloudflare Geld verdient hat.
Zumindest will ich für diesen Container eine Domain haben. Ich hab eine Idee, was dieser Container bekommt.
CAC-WWW bekommt er jetzt als Domain. Perfekt. CAC-WWW. Ich mein, das ist ein Web-Server. Gut, und wenn ich das jetzt starte, diese Configur brauch ich übrigens nur einmal.
Und jetzt sind wir auch schon gerade wieder beim Thema, warum das so gut ist, wenn man das in Git-Repo eincheckt. Ihr könnt nachvollziehen, was ihr wo wann gemacht habt.
Ihr könnt es auch einfach auf andere Rechner klonen und so was in der Richtung. Deswegen machen wir jetzt erstmal da ein Git-Repo draus. Git-Init.
Oh, guck mal hier. Leute. Wir können ihn auch anstatt Master, können wir ihn auch Main und Trunk nennen. Ich bleib mal bei Master.
Git-Status. Wir haben da nicht so viel drin in unserem Git-Repo außer unser Docker-Compose. Also Git-Add. Alles hinzufügen. Git-Commit-A-M-Init-Message. Wo bloß?
AddGamics.de. Es ist immer noch kein Leak, weil die Leute ja laufend irgendwas erzählen von Leak, Leak, Leak. Es ist immer noch kein Leak. Das ist nämlich die offizielle Adresse von dem Channel, wo auch die Paypal-Donations, die ich mittlerweile ausgeschaltet habe, drauf zeigen.
So. Jetzt haben wir das Ganze richtig agil eingecheckt in unser Git-Repo. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das mit den Zertifikaten funktioniert.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du. Was haben wir denn überhaupt hier für eine IP? Machen wir mal kurz DNS-Eintrag.
Du-du-du-du-du-du.
Kann man in dem Stream etwas über Shithub lernen? Indirekt nur.
Just a quick hello from traffic maintainer. Hello back. Returned hello. Okay. Also, was machen wir jetzt? Was machen wir jetzt weiter?
Bains Jam Max. Ja, der Chat mag das immer, wenn ich Englisch rede. Das finde der Chat echt nice.
Also, weiter im Text. Wenn wir uns mal die Domain angucken, ich pinge die mal kurz. Ihr seht, wenn ich die pinge, ich habe einfach einen Wildcard-Eintrag gemacht.
Das soll alles mal auf die IP zeigen. So, und jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt. Das ist das, worauf ich eigentlich raus will.
Ihr seht, diese Domain löst nur lokal auf. Nur lokal auflösen. CACWW löst auf. Und das ist ein offiziell registriertes Domain.
Das löst nur lokal auf. Und ich kriege jetzt ein gültiges Zertifikat, wenn ich das starte. Also, Docker Compose ab.
Und wir haben hier Debug an. Und wir starten das auch nicht im Hintergrund. Also, der sollte jetzt, wenn ich alles richtig gemacht habe, zuletzt Encrypt gehen und mir ein neues Zertifikat holen für CACWW.
Das ist ein öffentliches Domain, ja? Guck, wo ist es? Ein öffentliches Domain. Ich meine, CACWW ist halt nur Intel erreichbar. Aber es ist ein Domain, die gehört auch mir.
So, okay, also machen wir das Ganze jetzt mal. Docker Compose ab. Bam. So, er zieht sich erstmal die aktuelle Traffic-Version. Er startet Traffic und ihr seht schon, er holt sich jetzt das Zertifikat für die Domain.
New Record. Blablabla. Cleaning. Okay, hat anscheinend funktioniert. Probieren wir das mal aus. Machen wir den Browser auf. CACWW.raub.haus. Und zack, siehe da.
Der Hello World Container antwortet. Und es ist ein legit gültiges Zertifikat von Let's Encrypt. So wie man das haben will.
Und das Schöne daran ist, diese Config hier müsst ihr nur einmal machen. Danach geht das immer weiter. Das heißt, ihr könntet jetzt easy weitere Container anlegen.
Das ist echt cool. Und was richtig praktisch dabei ist, der kümmert sich auch komplett um das Erneuern des Zertifikats. Also sprich, das Zertifikat, ich zeige es euch mal, das läuft ja ab in 30 Tagen.
Okay, Expire, 25. August, 30 Tage. Na, 5. Äh, ja. 7.5. Und 3 Monate ist 8.8. ist August.
Stellst du das in dein Public GitHub, ich kann einen Gist machen oder so, viel mehr, da gibt es ja jetzt nicht so viel zu sehen. Äh, warum muss ich dann immer noch Zertifikate bei Digi...tja, eigentlich musst du das nicht.
Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn mehr sich Zertifikate zu kaufen. Bei uns auf der Arbeit sehen, machen sie das auch so. Bei uns auf der Arbeit, äh, äh, fantasieren sie sich dann immer so Sachen zusammen wie, ja das Vertrauen der Kunden wäre höher in gekaufte Zertifikate.
Meine persönliche Meinung ist, die Kunden scheißen drauf, die kriegen das überhaupt nicht mit. Und vielleicht haben die zu viel Geld. Vielleicht wollen die einfach mehr Geld ausgeben. Ich weiß es nicht.
Also du brauchst, eigentlich ergibt es keinen Sinn, so wirklich, ja. Und die Rate Limits von Netz Encrypt sind auch äußerst großzügig. Da kannst du hunderte Zertifikate erstellen im Monat, also das reicht normalerweise. Und wahrscheinlich kann man sich sogar eine Rate Limit irgendwie erhöhen lassen, wenn man viel ist.
Ist ne Versicherungsfrage, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was mit der Versicherung zu tun hat. Hast du einen eigenen DNS Server im lokalen Netz laufen? Äh, ich hab nen lokalen DNS Server laufen, ja. Äh, das ist der DNS Server auf meinem MikroTik Router, der dafür sorgt, dass ping keg www aufgelöst wird nach äh, der lokalen IP.
So. Und das Schöne ist, wie gesagt, das Zertifikat hab ich euch ja grad gezeigt, das läuft ab. Ups.
Äh, das Zertifikat läuft, läuft ab am 30. August. Und wenn ihr das hier über Traffic machen lasst, Traffic kümmert sich darum, dass das Zertifikat ein paar Tage bevor es abläuft erneuert wird und reloadet den Zertifikatscache, ohne dass du es neu starten musst. Also ihr habt quasi, wenn ihr das mit diesem Setup macht, immer ein gültiges Zertifikat, was sich komplett von alleine erneuert und verlängert.
Das ist tatsächlich echt nice.
Was hältst du davon, wenn man seinen Mailserver mit einem HTTPS Zertifikat stützt?
Überall wo es easy möglich ist, würde ich HTTPS only machen. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, da ist es schwierig. Zum Beispiel bei meinem Staubsauger.
Die meisten Leute denken sich jetzt auch immer, aber die schon öfters im Stream dabei sind, wissen das? Denke ich, was hat der Max mit seinem Staubsauger?
Mein Staubsauger hat ein Webinterface, den habe ich geflasht und da ein gültiges Zertifikat drauf zu bekommen, ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Das ist relativ abgespeckt, da kannst du kein Let's Encrypt selbst drauf laufen lassen und ich will auch meine Cloud Keys nicht unbedingt auf dem Staubsauger hinterlegen.
Aber das geht, das könnte man machen. Ich könnte zum Beispiel den Staubsauger über den Reverse Proxy laufen lassen, das würde funktionieren.
Oder aber ich könnte irgendwie einen Deploy Hook hier reinhauen, dass es dann per SSH schiebt auf den Staubsauger und den neu startet, was auch immer.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben. Aber das meiste, wo es einfach möglich ist, würde ich immer machen mit HTTPS.
Das Ding hat HTTPS Unterstützung. Das hat HTTPS Unterstützung, du kannst da Zertifikate laden, das ist gar kein Problem.
Du musst dich aber darum kümmern, dass du alle drei Monate geupdatest das Zertifikat automatisch dahin bekommst und das Ding neu startest. Das Deployment ist eher das Problem.
Die Heizung hat einen Webinterface, ja die Heizung hat auch indirekt einen Webinterface, die Thermostat haben einen Webinterface.
Also ich würde bei allem mittlerweile HTTPS nehmen, sofern es easy möglich ist.
Und wie gesagt, warum wir das heute machen, ist manche Services oder manche APIs im Browser funktionieren auch nur mit HTTPS.
PWAs auf dem Smartphone zum Beispiel, die Krypto-AP Geschichten, WebRTC Sachen teilweise funktionieren nur noch über HTTPS und nur mit gültigem Zertifikat.
Sonst sagt der Browser quasi, piss dich also, wenn du da mit ungültigem Zertifikat ankommst.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt im Prinzip ja noch nichts weiter gemacht, außer unseren Reversebox hier einzurichten und einen Hello World Container zu machen.
Jetzt machen wir mal weiter, oder wollte ich noch vorher irgendwas anderes zeigen? Nee, ich glaube das war's.
So, jetzt machen wir weiter. Wir sind ja agil heute. Wir machen jetzt einen Git Frontend da rein.
Und was ich auch lokal bei mir laufen habe, ist das da. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter lokaler Shithub-Klon.
Vielleicht wollen wir mal fragen, ob das jemand kennt. Chet, kennt das jemand?
Es sieht doch schon, ich mach mal kurz den Darkreader aus, es sieht relativ, oh Flashbang, Alter, meine Augen.
Also es sieht Shithub teilweise schon relativ ähnlich.
Das ist ja High Speed. Oh.
Okay, dann installieren wir es lokal. Bei uns sollte das nicht passieren.
Also das ist ein Git Frontend.
Also das ist ein Git Frontend. Ich persönlich bin ja der Meinung, man braucht sowas nicht.
Ich mach alles eigentlich git-technisch über die Kommandozeile, aber für so, ich will es nicht Archivierung nennen.
Aber für Projekte, wenn man Projekte hat, wo man dann nach einem halben Jahr oder Jahr oder so mal wieder drauf geht,
ist es ganz nice, wenn man die nicht lokal nur bei sich auf der VM liegen hat. Deswegen ist sowas schon okay.
Man kann damit auch die richtige DevOps Schiene mit Continuous Delivery und sonst was fahren.
Klar, kann man machen. Machen wir jetzt aber nicht. Wir installieren uns jetzt ein Git.
Wie spricht man jetzt eigentlich aus? Git-Tier, Git-T, Git-T wahrscheinlich.
Und allein schon, wenn wir unser eigenes Shit laufen haben, dann sind wir schon Next Level DevOps Status erreicht, Level Up.
So, das machen wir jetzt.
Dazu brauchen wir ein paar andere, dazu müssen wir ein paar andere Features verwenden.
Also, als erstes, neues Service anlegen.
So, Image. Was brauchen wir für ein Image? Wir brauchen Slash.
Und dann müssen wir wieder gucken auf Docker Hub oder auf die GitHub Container Registry oder sonst wie was.
Und suchen mal danach und gucken mal, was wir da zur Auswahl haben an Versionsnummern, die wir verwenden können.
Latest. Wie gesagt, Latest gibt es immer.
Aber wir nehmen als aktuellen Tag, was haben wir hier, 1.4. Wir nehmen 1.1.4.
Also sprich, wir bleiben auf dieser Version, außer Security fixes.
So. Ja, brauchen wir. So, dieses Image wollen wir haben. Container Name. Tja.
Container Name ist Shit Repo. Muss ja auch mal sein.
So. Und da kommt jetzt auch eine Sache, wo man bei Containern dran denken muss.
Manche Container und ich würde mal sagen eigentlich 90 Prozent der Container, die man, die man so als Service verwendet.
Die haben ja nicht nur Hallo Welt.
Die haben ja auch noch irgendwelche Daten, die man behalten will nach einem Neustart oder nach einem Container Neuaufbau.
Wenn du deinen Repos auf der Arbeit so. Nee, also meine Projekte auf der Arbeit heißen in der Regel mittlerweile irgendwas mit Champ hintendran.
Ich habe zum Beispiel letztens den Spam Champ, haben wir gemacht, zum automatischen Freigeben von Spam Nachrichten.
Damit ich mich anmelden konnte, bei einem Zwei Faktor Authentifizierung, habe ich mal den Auth Champ gemacht.
Was habe ich dann letztens noch auf der Arbeit angelegt? Spam Champ, Auth Champ.
Ja, und ich habe die üblichen Twitch Emotes an Ordner natürlich auch durch.
Also wenn du bei mir auf der Arbeit auf ein Notebook guckst, dann ist CacW, CacWade, Lul, LulW ist alles schon belegt.
Alles schon voll.
Also Container Name ist Shit Repo.
Und wie gesagt, wir wollen ja, dass das Ding sich Daten speichern kann.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt erstmal sagen, ok wo sollen denn die Daten hin?
Weil beispielsweise, also wenn ich dahin pushe mit Git, dann muss das ja irgendwo gespeichert werden.
Wenn ich das hier weglasse, dann erstellt er automatisch, ich setze mal ein Laufwerk für diesen Container.
Das Problem ist dann nur, dass ich das nicht richtig finde und es dann sonst wo liegt.
Das heißt die beste Variante ist, ok, wenn man weiß der Container muss irgendwelche Daten speichern
und man macht das über Docker Compose, dann ist meiner Meinung nach das beste, wenn man ihm sagt,
hey, leg im aktuellen Verzeichnis, wo auch das Compose File liegt,
leg einfach für den Container einen Ordner an, wo du dann deine Dateien reinschreibst.
So kann man das in dem Fall machen.
Jetzt legt er einen Ordner an, der so heißt.
Mounte den in dem Container auf diesen Punkt und da schreibt er dann alles möglich rein.
Das hat den Vorteil, wenn ich den Container lösche, Versionsupdate mache und wieder hochfahre,
sind alle Daten noch da.
Genau, und dann brauchen wir im Prinzip den gleichen Crempel, den wir hier oben haben, Labels,
dass der weiß, wo das Ding drunter erreichbar gemacht werden soll.
Gut, das ist kein Who Am I Container mehr, das ist das Shit Repo.
Das tauschen wir hier aus.
Und die, was machen wir denn für eine, habt ihr eine gute Idee für eine Domain?
Ne, wir machen Shit Repo.
Wir machen Shit.
Shit.
Punkt mal auf, Punkt mal aus, shit.
Ein Raid?
Echt?
Wer hat geradet?
Ach nice, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Danke schön für den Raid.
Projection TV.
Nice.
Ich hätte es eigentlich sehen müssen an den ganzen Emotes, die ich sonst nicht sehe.
Hab ich gar nicht geguckt.
Ich war gerade in meinem Router und hab DNS-Settings eingestellt.
Das hat meine volle Aufmerksamkeit verlangt, dass ich das gefunden habe.
Ja, schön, dass ihr da seid.
Vielleicht mal kurz zur Erklärung, was wir machen.
Massive, Massive Huge Raid.
Richtiger Poggers Raid.
Nur so vielleicht als kurze Erklärung, was wir heute machen.
Und zwar, wir richten lokalen Service ein für den Passport Manager inklusive gültigen
Zertifikaten.
Und auch so, dass das Ganze alle drei Monate aktualisiert wird.
Das funktioniert prinzipiell ja auch schon.
Also wir kriegen jetzt gültige Zertifikate für die Domain.
Das ist eine ganz normale öffentlich gültige Domain.
Also sprich, das ist meine.
Die habe ich mir mal irgendwann gekauft.
Und wir können jetzt Services lokal ansprechen, die nur lokal.
Ihr seht es da hier, wenn ich die Domain pinge.
Nur lokal läuft.
Und wenn ich da hingehe im Browser, obwohl das nur lokal läuft, habe ich ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Das ist das, was wir gerade gemacht haben.
Das Ganze geht natürlich über Let's Encrypt, weil Let's Encrypt die einzige Sache ist,
die das macht.
Über DNS-Challenge, damit man das ganze lokal verwenden kann.
So, so weit zur Erklärung.
So, und jetzt eine Rolle Shit-Repo.
Genau, mehr muss man erstmal nicht machen.
Ich sage euch jetzt aber schon gleich, es funktioniert noch nicht.
Weil eine Sache ist bei diesem Container anders als bei dem da.
Und zwar, der hat mehrere Default-Ports.
Der hat einmal einen Port für SSH und der hat einmal einen Port für das Web-Interface.
Und in dem Fall weiß Traffic nicht, welchen Port es verwenden soll für den Web-Server.
Deswegen muss man ihm das sagen.
Und das sagt man ihm so.
Ich copy-paste mir das einfach mal aus der anderen, aus der anderen Datei.
Und das sagt man ihm so. Man muss ihm sagen, hier, Load Balancer Server, Port 3000.
Sprich, nicht Port 22, sondern Port 3000.
Das ist eine ziemliche Kack-Sündags-Shit-Repo-Sündags von Traffic.
Wie gesagt, die Traffic-Config ist ziemlicher Pains-Champ.
Gerade die Config, diese Inni-Yammel.
Nee, was ist denn das?
Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich noch Inni-Files oder sowas.
Nee, Tommel-Files sind noch was anderes.
Hauptsache 30 verschiedene Config-Dateiformate.
Die ist richtig eklig. Die ist wirklich eklig.
Das wollt ihr nicht sehen, das wollt ihr auch nicht machen.
Traffic ist ein schönes Projekt, wenn man das bei Docker-Containern belässt
und die automatisch balancen lässt bzw. automatisch Reverse-Proxien lässt.
Dafür ist das super.
Für alles andere würde ich lieber den Engine X verwenden
oder wenn es einfach sein soll, den Caddy.
So, das war's. Mehr müssen wir nicht machen.
Ich mache mal meinen Docker-Compose aus und mache es wieder an.
Und wenn ich alles richtig gemacht habe, dann sollte er jetzt...
Man kann das übrigens auch reloaden.
Wenn ich alles richtig gemacht habe, dann sollte er jetzt einen neuen Ordner anlegen
für mein Shit-Repo.
Und ein neues Zertifikat beantragen für Shit.mau.house.
Schauen wir mal, ob er das macht.
Ja, HA-Proxy ist auch eine nice...
Stimmt, das habe ich heute noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Ich hatte heute eigentlich schon alle durch,
aber an HA-Proxy habe ich nicht gedacht.
Ja, HA-Proxy ist natürlich auch eine super Geschichte.
Haben wir auf der Arbeit relativ viele HA-Proxys.
Es gibt ein richtig nice GUI, habe ich letztens gesehen, auf GitHub.
Das ist auch recht neu, das Projekt.
Das war aber, glaube ich, nicht das.
Oder doch?
Doch, das war das, genau.
Das wollte ich mir schon eine Weile mal angucken, ob das was für uns ist.
Wie gesagt, wir haben auf der Arbeit relativ viele HA-Proxys.
Aber für Container-Setups finde ich, ist es mit Traffic tatsächlich relativ nützlich.
Allein schon, weil das den ganzen Krempel eingebaut hat.
Aber die Config ist teilweise schon echt painstampig.
So, wir starten den ganzen Kram jetzt und gucken mal, ob das funktioniert.
Atterberg, Dankeschön für den Sub.
5 Monate, huge subscription.
Subscriber, Subscriber.
Nice.
So, starten wir den Kram mal und gucken, ob er sich ein Zertifikat holt.
Er sollte sich jetzt ja ein...
Macht er was?
Shit. Shit.mau.hausholt er sich. Perfekt.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Also, Shit.
Bam. Oh.
Painstamp.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Übrigens, diese Meldung meinte ich, wenn das Zertifikat nicht stimmt.
Ich war ein bisschen zu schnell.
Ich glaube, der hat das Zertifikat noch nicht aktualisiert.
Aber ihr habt es gesehen, jetzt habe ich ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Es war eigentlich ganz praktisch, dass das jetzt mal einen Fehler gegeben hat.
So sieht es halt aus, wenn das Zertifikat nicht gültig ist.
Der generiert ein Standard Zertifikat, sobald er erkennt, dass er hier was loadbalancen soll.
Oder was proxen soll.
Und sobald er ein gültiges Zertifikat hat, dann nimmt er auch das.
So, jetzt können wir... Achtung Leute, Flashbang.
Boah, es ist hell.
Woodface.
Die Zone hast du bei Cloudflare.
Die Zone habe ich bei Cloudflare.
Und ja, falls mich jetzt einer darauf hinweisen will, ich habe den Key leaked.
Ich weiß, dass ich den Key leaked habe.
Aber ich habe bei Cloudflare eingestellt, dass das nur mit meiner aktuellen IP funktioniert.
Und ich leuchte nach einem Stream auch wieder.
Das ist umsonst bei Cloudflare.
Der DNS ist umsonst.
Bei Cloudflare sind die meisten Sachen basic umsonst.
Du bezahlst halt für extra Features.
Zum Beispiel die Analytik-Funktionen kosten extra.
Wenn du viel mit Workern machen willst, kostet es extra.
Die DDoS-Protection kostet mit den advanceden Features extra.
Musst du gucken, aber du kannst Cloudflare ohne Probleme verwenden für basic DDoS-Protection.
Für private Sachen und DNS.
Ach ja, und was man halt machen muss, ist, damit das Ganze funktioniert,
man muss bei seinem Domain-Registrar hingehen.
Und den DNS-Server umstellen, dass der für die Domain sagt,
hey, guck mal da, geh mal zu den Cloudflare-DNS.
Das ist das Einzige, was man machen muss.
Und das Schöne ist, bei Cloudflare, also nicht nur, dass sie kostenlos sind,
sondern, dass sie auch eine ziemlich gute DNS-API haben,
die du auch recht gut restriktiv einstellen kannst.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel in der Cloudflare-DNS-API einstellen,
dass das Token nur gültig ist für diese Domain und nur von dieser Absender-API.
Und auch nur ob Read-Write und so.
Das ist ganz praktisch, gerade für mich, wenn ich jetzt nicht will,
dass die Leute irgendwelche Sachen anlegen können auf meinem DNS.
So, also weiter im Text.
Das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren. Gucken wir mal.
Leute, ich mache mal wieder Dark Mode an, das hältst du ja nicht aus hier.
So, also, ihr seht, Web-Server und so funktioniert schon wunderbar,
hat gültiges Zertifikat, wir haben jetzt unsere eigene Shit-Repo am Start.
So, SQLite, wir bleiben bei SQLite, ich habe jetzt keinen Bock,
noch einen extra Datenbank-Container hochzufahren oder sowas.
Ist ja auch total übertrieben dafür. Für unser Test-Repo reicht das.
Das kann man, glaub, alles so lassen.
Wichtig ist, dass wir das hier ändern, auf die neue Domain.
Und die SSH-Domain sollten wir auch ändern.
SSH-Server kann auf Port 22 bleiben, das müssen wir gleich noch weiterleihen,
sonst funktioniert es nicht.
DB2-Backend.
Oh, ich hatte auf der Arbeit wieder Stress mit DB2.
Weiß nicht, ob ich euch das schon erzählt habe.
Es gab eine Sicherheitslücke in DB2 und wir haben so eine uralt DB2-Version noch.
Also, die ist irgendwie von, fragt mich nicht, 2008 oder so.
Das ist wirklich, also Staub angesetzt ist da noch nett.
DB2 ist eine Datenbank.
IBM DB2, guckt da. Also, man allein schon IBM sagt ja alles.
Die ist uralt. So, das guckt mal, aktuelle Version ist 12 und wir haben, glaube ich, Versionen...
6, glaube ich.
2008 ist noch neu. Tatsächlich, war mal 0W? Ach nee, Luv, Luv.
Ich habe gedacht, die heißt Codename 0W.
Es hätte auch gepasst, aber war es nicht.
Ja, tatsächlich, unsere Version ist in der Tat relativ neu, so wie es aussieht.
Zumindest hatten wir da echt Probleme.
Wir können die nicht updaten, weil die so alt ist und unsere Version hat ein Security-Update.
Und da habe ich gedacht, okay, ja, was machen wir jetzt?
Ich kann das nicht einschätzen, ich kann das nicht entscheiden.
Ich habe bloß den Auftrag zum updaten.
Und da bin ich, da habe ich ein Ticket aufgemacht bei den Anwendungsbetreuern, Ansprechpartnern.
Und die haben jetzt ohne Wissen, die haben 2 Wochen darum gemacht, um dann am Ende das Ticket zu schließen mit
Server befindet sich in der Ablösung. Lösungsdatum, Lösungsdatum 31.11.2021.
Und by the way, es ging um eine Sicherheitslücke, Remote Code Execution.
Ja gut, also mehr als sagen kann ich es nicht, mehr als sagen kann ich es nicht.
Einfach hinter eine Firewall packen, easy.
Nee, das ist nicht easy.
Du musst ja auf die Datenbank zugreifen können.
Und wenn du auf die Datenbank zugreifen kannst, musst du die Firewall aufmachen.
Also zumindest von allen Netzen, wo du auf diese Datenbank zugreifen kannst, ist dann schon einmal Remote Code Execution.
Ja klar, es geht immer noch schlimmer, es könnte aus dem Internet erreichbar sein.
Aber in der Regel sind so Backend-Datenbanken ja hoffentlich nie aus dem Internet erreichbar.
Aber trotzdem, es war wieder kompletter Witz eigentlich, wie das gehandelt wurde.
So, wir stellen jetzt mal unser Shitrepo ein.
Also bla bla bla, passt.
Wichtig, Admin-Account anlegen, Rout, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Leaked, Passwort.
E-Mail-Adresse, brauchen wir nicht.
Install.
Administrator-E-Mail cannot be empty, ok.
Rout, add, shit.
Kommt zwar nie an, aber man was solls.
Chat, chat, sei dir schon drin, ja.
Sei dir schon eingeloggt, eingeloggt.
Ja, Passwort, die kann schon mal vorkommen.
Haben die den standardmäßig Darkseam?
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, es gibt ein offizielles Darkseam, Leute.
Ein offizielles Darkseam.
Ab-Inni.
Ist doch nicht euer, ok.
UI-Section.
Ich geh doch jetzt nicht in irgendeine Inni oder editiert, oder was?
Kann ich das hier einstellen?
Settings.
Kann ich hier mein Theme einstellen?
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Wo stelle ich, wo stelle ich hier mein bevorzugte...
Das kannst du in deinem User-Interface ändern, ja, aber wo?
Account?
Das allerwichtig Darkseam, ah, hier.
Green?
Ok, ich mach mal kurz den Darkreader aus, guck, ob es funktioniert.
Naja, es ist nicht schön, aber zweckmäßig, würde ich sagen.
So, ok, also, unser Repo läuft.
Unser Gitfront entläuft.
Dann können wir jetzt bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich mal...
Unser Docker Compose einchecken, würde ich sagen.
Übrigens, es war keine allzu clevere Idee, wie ich das Ganze gemacht hab.
Ich hab nämlich in mein Docker Compose geschrieben, die Dateien sollen im gleichen Verzeichnis angelegt werden.
Das ist nicht so clever, wenn das hier mal ein Git Repo ist und ich alles immer einchecke,
weil ich will die Dateien aus den Containern ja nicht einchecken.
Was ich mir jetzt machen könnte, ist ein Git Ignore.
Das müsst ihr aber immer updaten.
Es wäre wahrscheinlich sinnvoller, die außerhalb hinzulegen, aber zeig's mal drum.
So, nachdem ihr heute das Super Hacker-Man DevOps-Modus aktiviert,
das müssen wir uns jetzt in Git Repo anlegen.
Add Repo, Name, Compose, Owner ist root, alles klar, passt, default, make repo, zack.
So, jetzt sagt er uns ein paar Dinge, was wir machen können.
Wir haben ja schon ein existing Repo.
So, und hier bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob das funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich wird das nicht funktionieren.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Wahrscheinlich wird das nicht funktionieren, weil das hier auf meinen lokalen SSH Server zeigt
und das nicht über HTTP geht.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Das heißt, ich werde wahrscheinlich das Ganze weiterleiten müssen auf einen anderen Port.
Aber probieren wir mal aus, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich wird es nicht funktionieren.
Ach, Moment. Ich will das über HTTP machen.
Ich will das gar nicht über mein...
...Cacquade.
Git Remote RM.
Ich will meinen Key nicht leaken.
Also meinen Private Key ist recht nicht, aber auch meinen...
...den anderen schon, aber ich weiß gar nicht, welchen ich da verwenden müsste.
Ich habe hier 50 Dateien drin.
So, also, das da wollen wir. So ist es viel besser.
Aber wie gesagt, ich denke, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Oh doch, tatsächlich.
Warum funktioniert das Ganze?
Weil...
...um geht das?
Netz-Stats.
Ach so, weil ich keinen lokalen SSH Server laufen habe, ne?
Ach, was labere ich für ein Scheiß? Es geht über HTTP.
Das ist doch mit SSH vollkommen irrelevant.
Alles gut. Ich habe jetzt nicht nachgedacht.
Das geht ja über HTTP. Dann kommt es ja direkt in dem Container raus.
Dann ist alles gut. Dann ist alles gut. Dann passt es.
Also, root. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Bam.
Und refresh.
Oh, wir haben unser Git Repo gepusht.
Docker Compose. Jammel. Eingecheckt. Alles gut.
Exzellent.
So, jetzt machen wir ein neues Commit.
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen doof, dass wir hier die Dateien jetzt im Git Repo drin liegen haben.
Aber das Schöne ist, die sind untracked.
Da interessiert sich Git nicht dafür.
Also, beste Commit-Message aller Zeiten.
Ich habe jetzt ein neues Commit gemacht mit den aktuellen Änderungen in meiner Compose-Datei.
Und weil ich diesen Ordner noch nie geadded habe, interessiert das Git nicht.
Also, Git interessiert sich erst dafür, wenn ich einmal einen Git-Add mache oder einen Git-Add minus Groß A.
Das wollen wir jetzt aber nicht.
Michael, 50 Billionen auch mal wieder da. Nice.
Du kriegst immer noch deine eigenen Emotes, ne?
Hyper-Subscription. Jetzt.
Da ist er. 10, 11, 12. Nein, 12 Monate.
Versprochen.
Aber schön, dass du wieder da bist.
Wisst ihr, was ich cool finde am Stream auf Twitch?
Ihr wisst, dass ich es mit Leuten normalerweise nicht so habe, ne?
Und mir fällt es Real-Life-mäßig übelst schwer, mich zu bedanken für irgendwas.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich für Komplexe habe oder so.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran, dass im Real-Life viele Leute ein Dankeschön für Dinge erwarten,
die ich nicht dankeschön wertig empfinde.
Wie auch immer.
So nach dem Motto, ich habe deine Kaffeetasse mitgenommen in die Küche.
Ohne, dass ich gefragt habe.
Danke schön, danke schön.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Irgendwie cringet es sich bei mir immer, mich für so banale Sachen zu bedanken.
Aber okay. Und die eine Sache, die ich gemerkt habe am Livestream ist, irgendwie baut man schon so eine gewisse Beziehung zum Chat auf.
Ich kann das schwer beschreiben.
Es ist komisch auf jeden Fall.
Also ich kann das schwer beschreiben.
Aber dementsprechend, warum ich dich jetzt hier gerade gesehen habe, Michael 50 50 Trillionen.
Es gibt einfach Leute, die merkt man sich.
Und ich meine das wirklich ernst, wenn ich mich für den Zap bedanke.
Obwohl es mich in Real-Life übelst cringe teilweise.
Aber hier freue ich mich immer, wenn ich wieder die Leute sehe, die ich kenne.
Das ist komplett anders.
Muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Du fandest das aktuelle Katzenvideo richtig gut.
Ja, ja, das ist also generell.
Meine Oma hätte jetzt gesagt, so nach dem Motto stelle ich nicht so an.
So bitte danke sagen kann man ja kann man doch wohl mal erwarten.
Und ich wurde früher auch immer dazu gezwungen, mich bitte und danke zu sagen.
Gerade was gezwungen.
Also ich ich wurde nicht geschlagen oder so, wenn ich es nicht gemacht habe.
Aber es wurde es wurde schon immer nahegelegt, dass das das jetzt das jetzt zu sagen.
Wahrscheinlich will ich das deswegen nicht machen.
Also halt nur bei Sachen, wo ich denke, ja, das ist nice.
Weil die meisten Sachen, wenn irgendwie einer was macht, das will ich gar nicht unbedingt.
Und was ist dümmer, als ich für eine Sache zu bedanke, nur um nett zu sein, die man eigentlich gar nicht wollte.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Egal Informatiker, weird Champ, weird Champ Social Problems.
So, aber wir wollten eigentlich ein Passwort Manager noch installieren.
Wir sind zumindest jetzt schon mal einen Schritt weiter.
Wir sind hyper agil und haben ein Git Repo, was wir im Web Interface von angucken können.
So, weiter.
Wir machen, wir pushen jetzt noch mal neues Comet.
Wie?
Ich hab meine Git Alias nicht hier.
Was ist denn da los?
Gut.
So, push.
Das Minus U können wir uns jetzt übrigens sparen.
Und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt muss ich bei der, wenn ich gerade bei muss, nochmal lustige Geschichte erzählen.
Also, das hier ist die einzig richtige Variante, wie man in ein Git Repo pusht.
Git push ist das Kommando, das ist das Remote und Master ist der Branch.
Also, das ist die einzig richtige Variante, also die voll ausgeschriebene Variante.
Man kann auch einfach nur Git push schreiben.
So, das funktioniert.
Das funktioniert so, aber erst seit ein paar Versionen.
Ein paar Versionen sind wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, drei Jahre oder so.
Zumindest früher waren die Default Settings anders.
Früher war das so, wenn man einen Git push gemacht hat, dann hat der alle lokalen Branches gepusht.
So, und wir hatten faule Leute bei uns im Team.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern?
Die hatten ihr Default Kommando so.
Git push minus minus force.
Was passiert jetzt, wenn deine Default Settings verkehrt sind?
Sodass Git push standardmäßig alle lokalen Branches pusht.
Auch mit Sachen drin, die man gar nicht haben will.
Tja.
Deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt, die einzig richtige Variante zu pushen mit Git ist so.
Git push Remote Name.
Das muss übrigens nicht Origin sein.
Das kann ich an der Stelle auch nicht oft genug sagen.
Und das verwirrt die Leute immer.
Origin ist einfach nur der Default Name des Servers, von dem man geklont hat.
Ja klar, du kannst das resetten und so.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Aber wenn dir einer 50 Branches gepusht hat, das ist trotzdem nicht schön.
Vor allem wenn du noch vielleicht irgendwelche Hooks dranhängen hast, die Sachen machen.
Naja.
By the way, mittlerweile dürfen die...
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es so.
Es gibt nur zwei Leute, die Force pushen dürfen in unserer Repo.
Das bringt euch nichts, wenn ich euch den Namen sage.
Ich sage es jetzt trotzdem, das ist der Tim und ich.
Mit dem Tim wollte ich demnächst mal ein Video machen, weil der arbeitet bei uns im Support.
Der ist in einem anderen Team als ich.
Aber der macht Vertretung für mich.
Das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Der macht ein bisschen Repo, gibt Repo-Support-Vertretung und Merch-Hilfe und so.
Der hilft den Leuten ein bisschen mit der Repo-Geschichte.
Deswegen hat er auch die Rechte da drauf.
Und die hat er ehrlich gesagt nur, weil ich mich mit dem ganz gut verstehe.
Und wir dementsprechend angefangen haben ihn einfach ein bisschen da mehr einzubinden.
Obwohl es eigentlich in seinem Team nicht so wirklich die Aufgabe ist.
Aber funktioniert wunderbar.
So und nur wir beide haben die Rechte zum Force pushen.
Und mit dem Tim wollte ich demnächst auch mal ein Video aufnehmen.
Weil der arbeitet nicht nur bei uns im Support.
Sondern da hat er vor.
Obwohl ich erzähl's nicht.
Ich sag mal so viel.
Er hat vorher schon bei einem anderen Unternehmen im Support gearbeitet.
Eins was ihr wahrscheinlich kennt.
Und da wollten wir mal ein Video drüber machen, so die schlimmsten Support-Erfahrungen aller Zeiten.
Da sind ein paar lustige Sachen dabei.
So also wir haben jetzt unser Shit-Repo am Start.
Wir haben gepusht.
Also wir sind super agil hier.
Hallo?
Keck wait.
Also immer.
Also hat funktioniert.
Wir haben unser Docker-Compose-File gepusht.
Das Schöne daran ist jetzt, wenn ich beispielsweise auf meinen Raspberry Pi gehen würde.
Und ich kann euch das übrigens zeigen.
Ich kann euch das zeigen.
Wir machen das jetzt doch einfach mal.
Ich glaub schon Passport-Safe kommen wir heute nicht mehr.
Das machen wir nach dem nächsten Stream.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich hab ja noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Ich zeig euch das mal.
Also eine schöne Sache an einem Git-Repo.
Mit einer Versionshistorie von seinem Docker-Compose-File ist.
Ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt.
Ich connecte mich mal auf meinen Raspberry Pi.
Was hatten wir dem Ding dann für eine...
Das da?
Hey da ist er.
Nice.
Easy.
Das war die Geschichte, wo wir versucht haben KVM zum Laufen zu bekommen glaube ich.
Ich hab... Was Max? Ich hab auf...
Moment, ich kann grad nicht lesen.
He lacks critical information.
Max, ich hab auf Arbeit jetzt angesagt, dass ich gerne weg vom...
First-Level-Telefonsupport möchte.
Oh, das kann ich verstehen.
Das kann ich echt verstehen.
Es gibt eigentlich keinen, der sowas gerne machen will.
Nächste Woche bekomme ich Feedback, ob das klappt.
Wäre richtig Poggers.
Es wäre Massive Poggers.
Wo willst du denn hin?
Das Richtsmonarch ist Telefonsupport.
Das Allerschlimmste ist das.
Also Telefonsupport ist so die Kombination von allem, was ich nicht...
Nicht mag.
Telefonsupport bedeutet nämlich, nicht nur viel Kontakt mit Menschen.
Zwar nur übers Telefon, aber mit Menschen.
Es bedeutet Kontakt mit vielen Menschen, die abgefuckt sind.
Das ist schon mal nervig, weil die dir dann auch von Keks gehen.
Und das Schlimme ist, Support bedeutet viel Kontakt mit Menschen,
die abgefuckt sind und die keine Ahnung haben.
Das in Kombination ist das Allerschlimmste.
Peter aus Indien von Microsoft Support kann ein Lied davon singen, wahrscheinlich.
Ich mein, Peter aus Indien scammt die Leute wenigstens noch und hat davon was.
Aber die normalen Telefonsupportmitarbeiter, die haben ja noch nicht mal was von.
Support ist wirklich das Schlimmste.
Michael 30 Trillionen, Hut ab, wenn du das gut findest.
Ich muss mich da immer dran gewöhnen, es gibt Leute, die machen das tatsächlich gern.
Der Tim macht es auch gerne. Ich kann es halt nicht verstehen.
Critical Alert von Microsoft, hold on, hold on.
Calling my manager.
Telefonsupport von Microsoft sind das Beste.
Du spielst in deinen Haaren. Okay, das ist natürlich eine äußerst detaillierte Beschreibung, die war jetzt enorm wichtig.
Lass mir das wissen.
So, also legen wir mal los.
Was wollte ich jetzt mal machen? Ich wollte jetzt auf Raspberry Pi klonen.
Also von der Theorie her sollte das folgendermaßen funktionieren.
Äh, Sekunde.
Check wait.
So, okay, passt.
Was, ich habe eine IT Ausbildung hinter mir und verstehe hier kaum was.
Ja, dann betrachte das hier noch als IT Fortbildung.
Only for high IQ.
Und du weißt, wie das ist? Je mehr Subs, je höher IQ.
Why? Warum?
Leute, gibt es hier wirklich jemand, der sagt, er hat noch nie was gelernt?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, wer ist öfters dabei und sagt, ich habe noch nie was gelernt?
Sogar ich habe schon was gelernt vom Chat.
Ich lerne öfters was vom Chat.
Wisst ihr, eine der besten Sachen, die ich vom Chat gelernt habe,
eine der besten Sachen, die ich vom Chat gelernt habe,
ist, dass man beim Anlegen einer VM hier neben drauf klicken kann und man bekommt den direkten Gigabyte Wert eingetragen.
Das ist das Beste, was ich vom Chat gelernt habe.
Das ist aber echt nice.
Das wusste ich noch nicht.
Ich dachte, man kann nur hier einstellen oder irgendwie Gedöns von Hand eintippen.
Noch mal eine Frage an dich, Michael.
Machst du wirklich acht Stunden am Tag dann Telefonsupport?
Das stelle ich mir trotzdem unglaublich anstrengend vor.
Ich weiß nicht, warum du das machst.
Das war das Beste.
Es gab sicherlich noch viele andere Sachen, aber das ist das Beste,
insofern, dass ich das fast jeden Stream brauche.
Man gewöhnt sich dran.
Wenn es hier eine Fortbildung sei, dann müsste du noch prüfen.
Ja, mache ich doch.
Nachher im Discord habe ich doch am Anfang des Streams gesagt, das ist alles prüfungsrelevant heute.
Ihr wollt es mir ja nicht glauben.
Aber ich meine das ernst.
Ihr wisst, ich habe ganz gute Kontakte zu IHK Frankfurt.
Ihr wisst, was passiert, wenn ihr durchfällt.
Hoch, was war das?
Knackst.
Kündigung ist raus.
Also, machen wir noch mal kurz weiter.
Chat gucken.
Natürlich, ich weiß, manche Leute kriegen das nicht mit.
Alles, was ich gerade in den letzten fünf Minuten gesagt habe, ist Kappa.
Nicht Pride, aber ich habe keinen normalen Kappa.
Kappa-Klepp.
Machst du irgendwann mal OpenStack mit Kuba?
Nein, das ist eine ganz schön umfangreiche Geschichte.
Da kenne ich mich aber auch selbst nicht so gut mit aus.
Vielleicht, weiß ich ja nicht.
Hast du die Domain nur für dein Heimnetz geholt oder machst du damit noch was anderes?
Also, die jetzt, die habe ich nur für meine Home Automation und Heimgeschichten geholt.
Ich habe noch ein paar andere.
Zum Beispiel, um mal Werbung zu machen, wird eigentlich der Preis-Champ.
So, was habe ich denn hier überlesen?
Du telefonierst so gerne mit anderen Leuten, dass du traurig bist nach dem Telefonieren.
Soll ich das jetzt wirklich glauben?
Aber gut, jeder hat ja so seine Sachen.
Gut, ich meine, es gibt halt Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen.
Ich hatte doch letztens auch jemand unter den Videos in den Kommentaren,
das war mal so ein Stellenanzeigen-Video,
der meinte irgendwie sinngemäß sowas wie,
ich bin Leiter eines mittelständischen IT-Unternehmens.
Ich kriege es nicht mal ganz so genau zusammen, ja.
Aber der meinte irgendwie sowas wie,
ich bin Leiter eines mittelständischen IT-Unternehmens.
Und bei uns ist das ganz anders.
Bei uns arbeiten die Leute nicht nur für Geld.
Bei uns geht es auch um Spaß an der Arbeit und um Plar und um das und jenes.
Und es geht nicht in der IT nur um Geld.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, meint er das ernst?
Und dann bin ich zu dem Schluss gekommen, der meint das ernst.
Und ich gebe ihm ja schon zum Teil Recht, dass Geld nicht alles ist.
Da gebe ich ihm ja Recht.
Aber so wie er das geschrieben hat, hat sich das eher angehört,
so nach dem Motto, man kann den Leute auch nur ein Apfel und ein Ei bezahlen,
solange der Rest irgendwie geil ist.
Und das ist Blödsinn.
Wenn du gute Arbeit machst und das Unternehmen auch ordentlich davon profitiert,
was du machst, dann sollten sie dich auch ordentlich bezahlen,
weil ansonsten ist die Frage, wie lange machen das die Leute denn noch?
Das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, zumindest meiner Meinung nach,
warum so viele Unternehmen sich so krass selbst feiern.
Wart ihr schon mal bei einem Unternehmen angestellt,
was nicht von sich behauptet hat, die besten zu sein?
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Es sind alle immer die besten und die geilsten.
Das ist ja alleine für sich genommen noch nicht schlimm.
Was da mit einhergeht, ist immer so eine Art Sektenbildung,
so nach dem Motto, die schwören die Leute immer voll ein auf den eigenen Laden,
sodass dann quasi, die wollen, glaube ich, dass die Leute so eine richtige Bindung entwickeln dazu.
Die sagen dann so nach dem Motto, boah, ich bin so glücklich, dass ich hier arbeiten darf.
Hier tue ich richtig was für die Menschheit und es ist so geil und wir sind die besten.
Ich bin so froh, dass ich hier sein kann.
Das ist, glaube ich, im Prinzip nur Taktik, dass man den Leuten weniger bezahlen muss unterm Strich.
Ja, so Hype-Veranstaltungen.
Wir haben auch auf der Arbeit so Hype-Veranstaltungen.
Das ist auch geil.
Das ist dann so eine, da haben wir dann irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, vier, fünf Redner.
Also Redner sind dann meistens Leute vom Betriebsrat, vom Vorstand,
Abteilungsleute, Leiterleute oder so.
Das ist dann eigentlich so eine Veranstaltung, wo es dann um verschiedene aktuelle Themen geht.
Und das sind halt immer Reden, wo im Prinzip zu 95% erzählt wird,
wie erfolgreich alles war, dass es noch viel besser gelaufen ist als erwartet,
dass wir weiterhin die besten sind und eigentlich kann uns eh keiner das Wasser reichen,
weil wir die geilsten auf dieser Welt sind.
So im Prinzip gehen diese Reden immer.
Und das Schlimme bei diesen Veranstaltungen ist gar nicht mal die Reden.
Letztendlich denke ich mir, ey, ich sitze da und wer dafür bezahlt, okay, dann schwingt halt Reden.
Das Schlimme ist, dass die von den Leuten, die da sitzen, erwarten, dass die alle zwei Minuten klatschen.
Da steht dann einer vorne und sagt dann, wir haben in, ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas aus,
der XYZ Rollout an den Außendienst hat ganz toll geklappt und der Außendienst ist super zufrieden.
Und das Quartalsergebnis ist noch besser als überhaupt je erwartet.
Und das ist nur möglich gewesen.
Dank Ihnen ein herzliches Dank an alle unsere Mitarbeiter.
Und dann musst du dir selbst klatschen, da komme ich mir immer richtig painstampig drin vor.
Also der bedankt sich bei allen Mitarbeitern.
Die Mitarbeiter klatschen dann für sich selbst oder, hä?
Ich cringe da immer so beim Klatschen.
Ich will da eigentlich gar nicht meistens mitklatschen.
Und da werden dann auch manchmal so banale Dinge erzählt.
Wie gesagt, ich will ja nicht zu viel erzählen und ich denke mir die Sachen jetzt ja aus,
aber im Prinzip geht es in diese Richtung.
Dann manchmal werden da total banale Sachen erzählt.
Und wir haben jetzt einen weiteren Erfolg errungen.
Unsere Kantine hat jetzt zwei Sitzplätze mehr.
Unsere Eingangstür ist jetzt fünf Zentimeter höher.
Oder solche Sachen.
Wir haben zwei neue Fahrradständer.
Wir müssen jetzt ohne Scheiß bei diesen Veranstaltungen klatschen alle 30 Sekunden.
Das ist echt der Witz.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, da klatsche ich auch dafür, wenn es halt was Cooles ist.
Zum Beispiel als derjenige vom Betriebsrat, der mir damals geholfen hat,
in meinem Teilzeitarbeiten und so, als der in den Ruhestand gegangen ist.
Da habe ich auch mal geklatscht.
Aber klar, der hat auch was Cooles gemacht für mich.
Da kann ich auch mal klatschen.
Zertifikatchamp, bitte.
Ich wollte mal gucken, ob ich denn irgendwas versehen habe.
Übersehen habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Im Prinzip ist das so.
Genau.
Das ist ähnlich zu dem, wo erzählt wird.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Leute, sie haben eh 22 Uhr.
Ich bin noch eine Weile on.
Ich bleibe noch kurz on.
Das ist ähnlich dazu.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Für die Leute beim Supermarkt, wo sie erzählt haben,
das sind unsere Helden im Alltag und auch bei den Pflegern.
Unsere Helden und wir klatschen.
Und ja, Pippo clap und alles.
Und es hat sich bei diesen Leuten aber nie oder nur zum kleinen Teil
wirklich auf dem Gehaltszettel ausgewirkt.
Wenn du den Leuten nicht mehr Geld bezahlst,
dann kannst du viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wenn du wirklich zufrieden bist und das schätzt
und es für wichtig erachtest, was Leute machen.
Die arbeiten ja nicht ehrenamtlich aus Spaß an der Freude,
dann gib ihnen mehr Geld.
Wie gesagt, ich bin auch der Meinung, Geld ist nicht alles.
Es gibt durchaus Vorzüge bei Arbeitgebern,
wo ich, also wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
zwischen zwei Arbeitgebern, bei dem einen kriege ich ein bisschen mehr Geld
und der andere hat, sagen wir mal, angenommen ich betrifft es jetzt,
hat Kinderbetreuung, hat eine Kantine, ist näher bei mir daheim dran,
hat irgendwie Jobtickets, hat irgendwie andere Sachen.
Also dann kann ich durchaus, würde ich durchaus sagen,
ich entscheide mich für den Arbeitgeber,
wo ich vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Geld bekomme.
Ein bisschen, wir reden jetzt hier nicht von 30% weniger oder so.
Ein bisschen weniger Geld bekommen, aber mir die Rahmenbedingungen besser gefallen.
Also wie gesagt, das ist nicht alles, aber im Prinzip 95% von dem, was wichtig ist,
ist, was kommt am Ende vom Monat rum.
Und ich persönlich würde sogar so weit gehen und sagen,
ich nehme auch eine ganze Ecke weniger Gehalt,
also wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen zwei,
ich würde auch eine ganze Ecke weniger, also wie gesagt 30% oder so,
aber schon einen gewissen Teil weniger Gehalt in Anspruch,
wenn ich wüsste, dass die Arbeitsatmosphäre bei dem einen zum Beispiel einfach viel besser ist.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl habe, ich kriege 10% mehr Geld,
obwohl es mich den ganzen Tag mit Vollspasten auseinandersetzen,
dann gehe ich lieber dahin, wo ich 10% weniger Geld bekomme
und es macht mir da Spaß und es gefällt mir und ich komme mit den Leuten gut klar.
Aber wir reden jetzt hier nicht von der Hälfte oder so.
Ja genau, wenn du, gibt verschiedene Sachen, wenn Homeoffice möglich ist, sonst was,
also es gibt viele Vorteile, die auch zählen,
die jetzt nicht unbedingt rein sich im Geld widerspiegeln müssen,
das können wir tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Wenn ich Projektideen, wo habe ich denn hier Streamideen?
Aber zum größten Teil geht es natürlich um das Geld,
weil die Leute gehen nicht arbeiten und haben Spaß an der Freude,
dann würden sie ehrenamtlich arbeiten gehen, weil sie Geld verdienen müssen.
Das sind die Balkonklatscher, so sieht es aus.
Haben Pfleger eigentlich mittlerweile mehr Geld bekommen
oder hat man das jetzt einfach nur zwei Jahre lang erzählt?
Wie sieht es mit Supermarktleuten aus?
Da ist man auch so abgegangen, nein wahrscheinlich nichts.
Der Cloudnet, ne der ist noch nicht vorbei, da sind wir eigentlich immer noch dabei.
Ich bin bloß gerade irgendwie ein bisschen vom Thema abgekommen.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die WhatsApp-Gruppe cringe ist.
Das ist ein bisschen so wie das Geschäftsleitungs- bzw. Vorstandsblock, was es bei uns gibt.
Da werden ab und zu mal Artikel veröffentlicht, unter anderem wie geil wir sind,
das ist ja immer so, das ist das Beste.
Liam Arthur, Dankeschön für den Sub und du hast so die üblichen Verdächtigen,
es gibt so ungefähr 20-30 Leute, würde ich mal sagen, bei uns,
die haben irgendwie eine Notification drauf, wenn es einen neuen Vorstand-Blockpost gibt
und die instant liken denen, instant, egal um was es geht.
Also die könnten jetzt einen Post machen,
wir entlassen 30% der Leute, weil Stonks und die würden instant liken, instant.
Also das ist so richtig Schleim-Action.
Dementsprechend kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass die WhatsApp-Gruppe auch richtig cringe ist.
Generell alle Chatgruppen, wo nicht dein direkter Chef drin ist,
oder sagen wir mal so, besten Chatgruppen, da wo keine Führungsperson drin ist in der Regel,
aber dein Chef ist meistens noch vollkommen okay, wenn er in Teams-Gruppen ist,
aber sobald der Chef von deinem Chef in einer Chatgruppe drin ist,
wird es meistens cringe.
Oder die Leute sagen gar nichts, eins von beidem.
Oh, Wahnsinn.
Ja gut, dass den Kram keiner macht.
Also acht Jahre erscheint mir schon relativ viel.
Mich wundert, dass den Kram überhaupt noch Leute machen wollen.
Gin9x, danke schön für den Sub.
Aber ich finde, dass es die letzten Jahre doch gerade im IT-Bereich hat sich da vieles getan.
Zum Beispiel eine Sache, die ich persönlich ganz gut finde und wie gesagt,
ich arbeite bei der Bank, wir sind bei sowas eh langsam,
dass die meisten Unternehmen in der IT mittlerweile gecheckt haben,
dass man Karrieremöglichkeiten bieten muss, die nicht aus Management bestehen.
Früher war das so, wenn du gute Arbeit gemacht hast in der IT,
wenn man so die richtigen Karriere-Crime machen wollte,
du konntest eigentlich nur Management-Sachen machen.
Irgendwelche Projekt-Management-Sachen, Teamleiter werden, Abteilungsleiter werden, was auch immer.
Das war so der einzige valid Karriere-Fahrt, was natürlich bescheuert ist,
weil IT-Profis wollen das in der Regel nicht und die sind ja auch gut in ihrer Position.
Die will man ja eigentlich auch nicht da verlieren, dass die auf einmal Management-Sachen gehen.
So, deswegen ist in den letzten Jahren hat sich vieles getan,
dass man auch nicht nur die klassische Management-Karriere machen kann,
sondern auch im technischen Bereich.
Und wenn es bei uns schon so ist, dann ist das in vielen anderen Bereichen schon längst gang und gäbe.
Topics, danke schön für sieben Monate Subscription.
Ja, hat jeder so seine Sachen.
Was, keine China-Hose?
China-Chinesen-Hose.
Eine China-Hose.
Dann eine China-Hose.
Aha.
Hab, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab ganz normale Jeans immer an.
Monka DSGVO.
Tja, da mach ich mir keine Gedanken mehr drüber.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Nichts für Boomer-Memes.
Hab ich euch schon mal...
Da geht es auch lustig sein.
Okay Leute, ich erzähle euch jetzt einfach noch ein paar Sachen.
Morgen mit der ganzen Geschichte weiter.
Ich erzähle euch noch mal eine coole Sache.
Von wegen Twitch-Chat auf der Arbeit.
Twitch-Chat auf der Arbeit.
Und zwar, wir hatten letztens so einen Code-Camp.
Das hab ich euch ja glaub erzählt.
Wo ich tatsächlich freiwillig mal was am Wochenende gemacht hab.
Und wo es um die innovativste App und so ging.
Hab ich euch ja mal erzählt.
Und wo wir nicht gewonnen haben...
Egal, ich fang davon nicht wieder an.
Aber worauf ich raus wollte, die haben eine Abstimmung gemacht.
Zwischendurch.
Wo man so voten konnte.
In so einer App.
Und da kam dann irgendwann die Frage.
Was haltet ihr von der Cloud?
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie so in der Richtung war die Frage.
Was haltet ihr von der Cloud?
Und ich hab dann einfach die App aufgemacht.
Ich hab reingeschrieben Poggers.
Ganz groß, Poggers.
Und was macht der Typ, der das vorliest?
Was macht der Typ, der das vorliest?
Er sagt, aha, Poggers seh ich hier schon.
Wortwörtlich Quote, aha, Poggers seh ich hier schon.
Das heißt, wir haben es zum ersten Mal geschafft.
Das Twitch-Emote im Frankfurter Banken-Business-Meeting zu etablieren.
Poggers, ja.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob er das Wort wieder erkannt hat.
Weil er selbst Twitch guckt.
Oder ob er das einfach nur vorgelesen hat.
Aber ich glaube, er hat das selber erkannt.
Weil er hat es nicht Poggers ausgesprochen.
Sondern hat es Poggers ausgesprochen.
Und ich glaube, der wusste das.
Und ich glaube, da guckt Twitch, der Typ, der das vorgelesen hat.
Er hat erst mal Poggers in den Chat geschrieben.
Bei welcher Bank, das sag ich nicht.
Okay, das ist natürlich eine doofe Kombination.
Ich komm mit meinem Chef deutlich besser klar als mit dem Chef von meinem Chef.
Und gar mit dem Chef vom Chef vom Chef.
Cloud-Native-Experten wollen Hackermann.
Ja klar.
Die geklaute Idee, genau.
Bei diesem Code-Camp, wir hatten mit Abstand die beste Idee.
Mit Abstand, mit Riesen.
Also bin ich echt davon überzeugt.
Mit Abstand.
Wir waren die Einzigen, die den funktionierenden Prototyp von der App hatten.
Und wir haben nicht beschissen.
Wir haben nicht vorher angefangen.
Wir haben das wirklich gemacht in diesen zwei Tagen am Wochenende.
Also meiner Meinung nach war das echt das Beste.
Obwohl, man hat das ja auch Code genannt.
Also als hätte was, als sollte man was programmieren.
Und am Ende, wisst ihr wer am Ende gewonnen hat?
Am Ende hat eine Gruppe gewonnen, die keinen funktionierenden Prototypen hatten.
Die die exakt gleiche Idee hatten wie wir.
Aber die sich zwei Tage hingesetzt haben und eine geile Präsentation gemacht haben.
Ich meine unsere Präsentation war vielleicht jetzt nicht die beste auf der Welt.
Aber schlecht war die auch nicht.
Ähm, aber ach ja und dazu wurde noch gecheatet.
Es hieß maximal fünf Leute und das waren glaube ich acht.
Das habe ich danach auch im Feedback reingeschrieben habe ich gesagt.
Also wenn man sagt fünf Leute, dann sollen das auch gefälligst fünf Leute sein und nicht acht.
Also ich glaube es geht los.
Ich hätte den Scheiß schon gerne gewonnen, sage ich euch ehrlich.
Zumal es mit Abstand die beste Idee war und auch der beste Prototyp.
Also eigentlich das was zählen sollte hat nicht gezählt.
Ich war sehr überzeugt von unserer App und unserer Idee.
Und das war immer noch die beste und auch die beste App mit den besten Funktionen.
Egal, naja.
Max kurze Frage.
Ich muss mir ein paar Standard Dinge, die ich jeden Tag erledigen muss zu automatisieren.
Nur die Frage ist, ich habe bei manchen Dingen ein Auto login, wo das Passwort bisher verschlüsselt in der TXT Datei steht.
Hast du eine bessere Idee?
Ja, SSH Keys verwenden.
Guck mal da, wenn ich mich auf einen Raspberry Pi einlogge, dann geht das auch ohne Passwort.
SSH Keys verteilen.
Das machst du folgendermaßen, SSH Copy ID.
Äh, ne Moment.
SSH Copy ID, dann kopierst du das da drauf auf den Server und wenn du das einmal gemacht hast, kannst du dich ohne Passwort einloggen.
Easy.
Ach ja, ich wollte ja das Git Repo noch auf den Raspberry Pi klonen.
Ja das mache ich jetzt noch schnell.
Ok, wo ist der Knopf fürs Klonen?
What the?
Dann lese ich den Chat noch fertig. Wo ist der Klonen Knopf? Da.
Ok.
Hab ich Docker überhaupt drauf?
Nee.
Install.
Docker.
Compose.
Oh, das ist so ein uraltes Docker, oder?
Auf dem Respian, das ist so ein uralt Docker.
Das wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren richtig.
Ok, während das installiert, gucke ich mal weiter.
Ja, aber hier, Nichols, also SSH Passwort, beste.
SSH Keys nicht, SSH Passwort.
Halt Stop, wieso?
Was ist?
Hack Wait.
So, Docker, PS, Hammer drauf.
Git, Klonen.
Guck mal, ob das...
Achso, das ist auch das Falsche.
Ach guck mal, das ist ein Bug. Wir haben einen Bug gefunden, kann das sein?
Wir haben einen Bug gefunden.
Woan hatte die P-Klon?
Was?
Ich hab das in meinem Router drinsteht im DNS, das sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
Hack Wait.
Na gut, ich meine, ich kann Hosts eintragen machen, aber warum nimmt er meinen Router-DNS nicht? Was ist da los?
Was neu...
Nee, nee, nee, ich hab's in dem Host, ich hab's im DNS stehen.
Ich meine, ich kann den, aber warum?
Ah!
Hack Wait.
Der nimmt Google-DNS, keine Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Könnte man wirklich als Videotitel nehmen, was?
Was könnte man als Videotitel nehmen?
Was denn? Schreib's nochmal, Chet, ihr müsst mich... da, ich komm da nicht mit, wenn ich hier guck.
Okay, keine Wunder, dass es das nicht auflösen kann, ich ändere das jetzt nicht, ich schreib das jetzt hier von Hand rein.
Äh, Moment. Hack Wait, stimmt ja nicht. Äh, äh, was hat mein Raspberry Pi für ne...
Ach, was mach ich denn für ein Plötzchen, das ist doch richtig, was ich hier mache.
Clone.
Ah, jetzt hat er's geklont, alles klar.
Shit, Repo auf dem Abfall-Server im Rechtzentrum, das ist eine Quatsch, das kann ich nicht als Titel nehmen.
Okay, also, Compose, da ist das Repo, Docker, Compose, ab.
So, ich hab's jetzt geklont auf meinem Raspberry Pi und er sollte es exakt so machen wie auf meinem Host.
Guck, einfach nur die Datei ausgecheckt, er macht nen Traffic-Container, er macht nen Who-Am-I-Container,
alles anhand meines Docker-Compose-Files, was ich auf meinem lokalen Rechner erstellt hab.
Mach der jetzt auf dem Raspberry Pi in Git-Server, natürlich funktioniert das alles immer perfekt.
Kann es sein, dass es kein Arm-Image gibt davon?
Es gibt kein Arm-Image von...
Ja gut, dann kann ich ja nix für, wenn es kein Image von Raspberry Pi davon gibt, das wäre nicht mein Problem.
Da kann ich auch nix für machen.
Keck wait.
Ne, das ist ja... da kann ich nix machen.
Also wenn es kein Image dafür gibt, aber ihr habt gesehen, dass das prinzipiell easy funktioniert.
Datei rüber kopiert, oder rüber in das repo geklont, ausgeführt, gut ist.
Nein, ich vertraue dem Chat nicht.
So weit vertraue ich dem Chat nicht.
Sagen wir mal so, ich vertraue dem Chat in so weit, dass ich Geld von ihnen für Subs nehme, ja.
Aber mehr?
Ne.
Raspberry Pi in Git... ne, mach ich nicht jetzt.
Das lass ich so.
Only debated scam, ja.
Wo sicherst du dein SSH private key?
Ja, der liegt in meinem Heimatverzeichnis, im SSH-Verzeichnis.
Wenn ich Backups mache, ist das ja dabei im Heimatverzeichnis.
Also ich nehme ja Borg-Backup für meine Backups.
Und wenn ich das Heimatverzeichnis sichere, ist dann mein SSH key auch dabei.
Was ich bescheuert finde, ist Docker über Snap, ja.
Snap ist an sich Paynes-Champ, richtiger Paynes-Champ.
Snap ist so eine Ubuntu-Geschichte, ja.
SSH1?
Ne.
Das beste Passwort ist 123456.
Best Practice Passwort.
Jetzt kann ich den Titel nehmen, das verstehen die Leute doch nicht.
Das verstehen nur die Leute, die die anderen beiden Videos geguckt haben.
Raspberry Pi aus.
Off.
Nicht, dass ich nachher wieder ausschalte oder dann auch wieder die SD-Karte kaputtmache.
Was ist eigentlich jetzt mit einer doppelten DNS-Challenge?
Was für eine doppelte DNS-Challenge?
Funktioniert doch alles.
Ach so, du meinst, weil er zweimal die gleiche Domains anfragt?
Das ist kein Problem.
Solange du unterhalb dem Rate-Limit bist von Let's Encrypt, ist das kein Problem.
Du kannst auch zehnmal die gleiche Domain anfragen.
So, nice.
Ja, das mit dem Passwortserver machen wir morgen im Stream.
Wir machen das noch fertig.
Es gibt noch einige Punkte, die wir hier beachten müssen bzw. die wir hier noch ergänzen und besser machen können.
Das machen wir mit dem Passwortserver, machen wir morgen.
Morgen ist Samstag, ne?
Chat.
Recht?
Ich glaube schon.
Samstag, ja.
Ich bin verwirrt irgendwie gerade.
Massive Verwirrung.
Eigentlich müsste man das wissen.
Leute, ich sage euch, zu Zeiten, wo ich noch Vollzeit arbeiten gegangen bin, da wusste ich das immer.
Heute überlege ich mir manchmal abends sowieso, muss du morgen arbeiten gehen?
Und dann fällt mir, ach nee, morgen ist ja Samstag.
Oh, welche Uhrzeit?
Morgen ist, ist da irgendwas?
Ja, also ich muss morgen auf jeden Fall die Teile aufnehmen für mein Programmier-Sprachen-Einsteiger-Sprachen-Video,
wo wir ja Kollaboration machen.
Ja, und noch ein paar Sachen, also wahrscheinlich nachmittags.
Vielleicht auch schon mittags.
Mal gucken.
Weiß nicht, genau.
Wir hausten übrigens mal den Cyrus, da spielt Resident Evil.
Da bin ich auch am Überlegen, ob ich mir das kaufen soll.
Das neue Resident Evil, was taugt.
Ich bin kein Riesen-Resident-Evil-Fan, aber das sieht auf jeden Fall recht nice aus.
Aber wir spielen das nicht im Stream.
Soll ich auch gleich.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Spiel, wo ich nicht lange dranbleiben werde.
Beste Einsteigersprache ist GoGo ist mit dabei.
Ja.
Raids.
Raiden.
Massive.
Huge.
Poggers-Raid.
Könnt ihr da einmal eine Runde mit Wupp-Pock oder Wupp-Gasm oder immer Vollspam.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Dann morgen im Stream.
Bis denn.
Uff.
Uff ist überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt zu sagen.
Das ist sowas von 2019, 2020.
Uff.
Sagt keiner mehr.
Also bis denn.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.